what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so I'll be honest with you guys when it
came to the Green Lantern mythos it had
always been so daunting to me I mean
because it was so huge in scope there's
really never been anything like Geoff
Johns run on Green Lantern the only
thing that I can think would be
equivalent to that from like Marvel for
example would be like if Jonathan
Hickman instead of writing the Avengers
in New Avengers leading up to Secret
Wars he had started all the way back
with Civil War then he covered Secret
Invasion then he covered you know the
Avengers initiative then he went to you
know dark rain and then siege and then
fear itself and then the heroic age and
all those things that led into Hickman's
you know his Avengers of New Avengers
run going up to seeker wars Geoff Johns
writing of the Green Lantern mythos is
that expansive it literally changed
everything about the Green Lantern
mythos not only that you also had
contributing writers more specifically :
Bunn with regards to the history of
Sinestro himself and so because of the
fact that this channel exists to explain
things because of the fact that this
channel exists to make sense out of
comic books and give you a place as far
as what you're looking to do is get into
a series we're gonna do exactly that
when it comes to the Green Lantern
mythos and DC Comics Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern Corps is really more
designed for seasoned readers for those
fans who have been following the series
the entire time Green Lantern's is
designed for those individuals who want
to get into the mythos and quite
literally learn about the Green Lantern
mythos as Simon Baz and Jessica Cruz
learn about it but it doesn't mean that
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps
is designed to alienate new readers not
at all in fact there's really only a
couple things maybe three things that we
need to know before we start getting
into Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps the first of these is Sinestro now
in the new 52 DC launched a Sinestro
centric line of stories and these were
quite literally designed to just focus
on Sinestro himself not only that they
also offered a little bit of retconning
with regards to his history prior to and
really during the early days of Jeff
Jones run on the Green Lantern mythos it
was always just assumed that Sinestro
was at one point a Green Lantern he had
become drunk with power he had basically
tried to force order on his homeworld
cruder and Asura's
he was looked at by the guardians of the
universe as having abused his power who
was exiled from the core and eventually
Sinestro became a yellow lantern and
formed his own Sinestro court that was
the universal standard with regards to
his history right
what DC did is they came along and they
said that was not necessarily the case
instead somewhere along the line
Sinestro had a daughter named ceramic
and what happened was he came to the
realization that his homeworld kuru ger
was just too chaotic for a child to be
raised in and so as a Green Lantern he
chose to basically enforce order on the
planet so that his child could grow up
in a suitable environment because of
this he was cast out of the of the Green
Lantern Corps and ultimately forma
Sinestro Corps in response to this now
because of that things began to unfold
as we saw with the Sinestro Corps war
different things like that what's
happening here with this particular
story what Robert Venditti is doing is
he's basically taking the concept of the
Sinestro Corps war and he's turning it
on his head with the original Sinestro
Corps war they were the they were
basically the ones on the outside trying
to break their way in right the Green
Lantern's were the established police of
the DC Universe the Sinestro Corps were
the ones who were infiltrating with this
is the opposite circumstance with
sinestro's law instead and the events
that led up to DC rebirth the Green
Lantern Corps in its entirety
basically vanished they disappeared in
the beginning nobody really knew where
they had gone to and even now in the the
Green Lantern comics new earth nobody
really knew what had happened to them
now we as the reader know that the Green
Lantern Corps with regards to Jon
Stewart and Guy Gardner and all those
other members had basically been thrust
into the past into the last days of the
universe prior to the current one and so
they were basically lanterns out of pawn
but there was no Green Lantern Corps in
the DC Universe and so because of this
this allowed Sinestro to have the
Sinestro Corps move in to becoming the
protectors of the of the DC Universe to
basically take the place of the Green
Lantern Corps now what happened with
this there was a story author was
written called the palings and the
palings were led by a guy called the
paled bishop I believe and this story
centered on the idea of the palings
lacking emotion there was no real ties
to emotion to them well the problem with
that is the Lantern cores exist based on
emotion each Lantern core has a source
of power which is an entity we have
parallax for the yellow lanterns and you
have the ball
for the Red Lanterns so on and so forth
but because of the fact of the palings
couldn't feel emotion the powers of the
Green Lanterns were limited only in so
far I guess the powers of all the
lantern cores were limited only insofar
as their ability to create constructs
that could physically combat the palings
instead they couldn't instill fear in
the palings and turn them to their cores
and so what happened here is a Sinestro
Corps basically took over the mantle as
the police of the DC Universe and they
started fighting off against the palings
now it was it was literally a universe
wide conflict I mean it involved
everybody fighting on behalf of the
Sinestro Corps against these palings and
the pale Bishop ultimately Sinestro was
successful in this the problem was that
prior to the Green Lantern's vanishing
his daughter ceramic had become a more
intricate part of his life and so where
she was originally a Green Lantern she
was more or less forcibly inducted into
the Sinestro Corps by Sinestro himself
but she never really shared their
feelings now we'll get into that more as
we go through the story because she's
really one of the central characters in
this event and it's really cool to see
where Robert even dude he's doing with
the evolution of her character but the
fact remains here that once the the
battle with the pale Bishop was over
Sinestro at least it's alluded to the
idea that he had more or less kind of
sacrificed part of his soul for the
purpose of defeating the pale Bishop and
because of this he wasn't really a
full-strength
anymore he wasn't at full capacity now
this is where things get a little bit
hairy and the reason why is because DC
rebirth was planned out quite a bit
before the conclusion of the Sinestro
story and I was talking to Benny about
this and he had mentioned that robert
van diddy had been told that by the time
the Sinestro story was going to be over
this semester was going to be old but we
know that with issue number 23 of
Sinestro he was still relatively young
and he wasn't nearly as old as he looked
during the events of Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern Corps rebirth and so what
the rebirth issue was designed to do was
to basically wrap up those loose ends
regarding the edge of oblivion and lost
lanterns regarding Sinestro looking old
how to restore him to his youth so on
and so forth but more so than that it
also focused on Hal Jordan now with
regards to chronology of the Green
Lantern mythos and the DC rebirth the
universe Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's takes place before Green
Lantern's rebirth and the reason we know
this is that how Jordan was not one of
the lanterns one of the green lanterns
that found himself thrown back in time
to the previous universe instead what it
has
and is that over the course of the the
events that took place and Jeff Jones
run all these different conflicts that
had happened wrath of the first Lantern
and you know rage of the red lanterns
and so on and so forth even a Sinestro
Corps war itself in society had sort of
begun to lose faith in the Green
Lantern's and the reason why was that
because on a personal level the various
citizens of the DC Universe didn't look
at it as the Sinestro Corps are the ones
that are trying to take over the
universe they simply saw it as a
conflict between the Green Lantern's and
everyone else and because of the fact
that the Green Lantern's while they were
protecting trying to protect the
universe because of the fact of these
conflicts spilled over into other
planets because it saw the destruction
of other races and so on and so forth
the various inhabitants of the universe
began to sort of shy away from the Green
Lantern's and so what this did is this
led into Hal Jordan effectively falling
on his own sword basically more or less
taking the stance that he would come out
or he would look to be the renegade of
sorts and in response the Green
Lantern's would seek him out now this
was all just an illusion and it was
designed to restore the honor of the
Green Lantern's in the eyes of the
universe's citizenry the problem with
this was that the edge of oblivion event
happened and suddenly the Green Lantern
Corps was gone them so this left Hal
Jordan without a power ring that left
Hal Jordan without the ability to be a
Green Lantern and so what DC rebirth did
with regards to Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern's rebirth is it came along and
it had Hal Jordan more or less becoming
willpower in and of itself and the way
this worked was that while he was on the
run he had taken an artifact that had
previously belonged to Crona and I'm a
little fuzzy exactly on how this
artifact worked but it allowed him to
basically operate as a green lantern
without actually having a Green Lantern
ring the problem with this was that the
effects of the gauntlet on Hal Jordan at
least it seemed to more or less merge
Hal Jordan with willpower in and of
itself and so instead of Hal Jordans
simply just manipulating the Green
Lantern ring and using willpower he was
becoming willpower
now this created a whole new set of
events because it really heightened the
power of what it was that Hal Jordan was
capable of the issue with this was that
at the same time it seemed as though Hal
Jordan in his traditional sense that is
to say as a normal human being was
beginning to fade away beginning to go
away and so what happened here is that
in the
Hal Jordan the green ruler green lantern
rebirth mythos Hal Jordan had come to
the conclusion that with the Green
Lantern's gone they have to return in
some former fashion not only that he has
to find out where they went to and so
what he did is he quite literally used
the power of will use this weird
situation that he had with regard to
these new abilities and made a Green
Lantern ring using willpower now the
reason why this is such a big deal is
because traditionally and prior to this
it was believed that only the guardians
of the universe could do that that a
sentient being couldn't just come along
and create a Green Lantern ring and the
reason why was because if it was common
knowledge if everybody could create a
Green Lantern ring or create any kind of
a Lantern ring did anyone could make a
Lantern ring anywhere and there would
just be this whole host of lanterns all
over the place it wouldn't mean that
we'd have 9,000 different parts of the
emotional spectrum but what it does mean
is you would have groups all over the
place you'd have green lantern group
here and a Green Lantern group there and
a Green Lantern group over there and
they would all operate you know separate
from one another
they'd have conflicting themes and it
would literally lead to a civil war
between all of the lantern cores and so
because of this the idea was to always
keep that knowledge constrained to
always keep anybody from being able to
use that knowledge more so than that
what this does is it elevates Hal Jordan
it says that Hal Jordan is no longer
just the greatest of the Green Lantern's
instead he's the definitive Green
Lantern not only that he'll likely
become the source of power for all the
Green Lantern's but again at this point
were really just kind of kind of
spitballing that's getting into
territory that were not 100% sure about
and so because of the fact that Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern rebirth events
started with Sinestro being old which
was contrary to how it was supposed to
start with regards to him maintaining
his youth at the end of the original
Sinestro story what Robert VIN did he
did is he basically came along and he
had Sinestro merged with the parallax
entity Ness is only happened maybe once
or twice before but it was just
basically a way for robert van de da to
restore the youth of Sinestro and so
because of the Sinestro now returns to
his position as being head of the
Sinestro Corps not only that relevant
Diddy doesn't simply just write it off
and just say well it's just a way to
return him to his youth the he ties it
into the story which is actually really
well done what he says here is that with
regards to
Sinestro returning to his youth this was
all part of the plan that the plan was
to look at his daughter who was
true istic to make her head of the
Sinestro Corps and in the time between
the the end of the semester Oh series
and the start of Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern's Green Lantern Corps
rebirth that she would basically start
moving the Sinestro Corps in a direction
to her not only would they be the police
of the universe to take the place of the
Green Lantern's but society the the
citizens of the universe would grow to
love them and when that point came when
it came to the point where the citizens
of the universe welcomed the Sinestro
Corps as their police then Sinestro
would make his move he would reinstate
himself as head of the Sinestro Corps
and then he would grab absolute power in
the universe and that's exactly what
happened here when he made himself young
the idea was to basically make himself
put himself at absolute control and he
even tells his daughter this when she
shows up and she says what's going on
here why are you young you know he says
well this was all part of the plan now
he's a little iffy about it right now he
doesn't necessarily come out and say
haha I tricked you instead she's the one
that actually figures it out first and
she said so you were always going to be
better all you had to do was merge the
parallax entity you always knew you had
to do that
why wait now and so then he says well
the idea was to basically have you move
the Sinestro Corps into being the police
of the universe people would welcome us
and then I'll take over control now the
reason why he does this is because the
Sinestro Corps feeds on fear that's
basically how it powers itself and so if
they're in if they're in absolute
control of the universe if they're
spread to every corner of the universe
he does exactly what makes sense he
tells his Sinestro Corps to go
throughout the universe and spread fear
everywhere that way it'll bolster the
power of the Sinestro Corps now the
reason for why he does this will
actually become clear here in a little
bit but what I want to do is I want to
transition back to how it's written here
and the reason why is after Hal Jordan
had arrived on earth and he had made or
I guess he had gone to Simon bast and
Jessica Cruz and said you are now
members of the Justice League
you are also Green Lantern's you guys
are going to share a central battery
core that way you or I guess a a power
battery core that way you all can you
know you'll be forced to work together
when he had taken off into space to find
the Green Lantern's that's the early
part of the story that's really all he
does in the beginning of this is him
hunting around trying to find the Green
Lantern's now he doesn't irrigate
various people but in the midst of the
Sinestro Corps traveling around the
universe and instilling fear in his
various citizens Lord
bolster their power a couple of them
come across Hal Jordan now I'll be
honest with you guys I had never really
considered the Green Lantern mythos to
be something epic right now me to me it
was like yeah Green Lantern's they can
do stuff there's Lantern cores whatever
this story totally changed my mind it
was not only is the story amazing Guy
Gardner is a badass like it's it's so
cool but Hal Jordan like Robert Gandini
really establishes in us what Hal Jordan
was capable of the worst case scenario
for the Sinestro Corps is that if there
were only going to be one Green Lantern
left in the universe that would be Hal
Jordan that's the worst situation they
could have because Hal Jordan is the
definitive Green Lantern he's the one
guy that not only has what it takes to
make the Green Lantern Corps great again
to reinstate him but he's also the
greatest of them in the sense of his
battle prowess his intelligence and so
on and so because of this with these
couple members of the Sinestro Corps
initially come into contact with him the
idea is they believe that can take Hal
Jordan out they believe they can
actually you know take him off on their
own now sinestro's told that Hal Jordan
has been discovered but Sinestro
initially freaks out about this because
his idea you know when he's informed by
this his thought process is this is the
worst thing that could have happened
this is the worst situation that could
have happened we don't need Hal Jordan
here because he will he's literally a
one-man army and he will just disrupt
everything that's going on now is
something else to also take note of is
that this comic also features the return
of the of the Green Lantern Corps to
this universe now we're not given a
whole lot in terms of you know what this
means initially but what we are told is
that the ranks have been thinned that
where the Green Lantern Corps almost in
its entirety was sent to this old
reality that about 90% in maybe 95% of
their fighting force was obliterated on
their journey back and so because of
this they're at a fraction of their
number now with regards to the Green
Lantern Corps under the control of Jon
Stewart and with you know Guy Gardner
sort of as a second-in-command or at the
lease as one of his most respected one
of his most respected members they're
stuck in a pickle here they're stuck in
a in a rough situation and the reason
why is because they don't know what's
going on in the universe right now not
only that the universe is a huge place
and their number is small their
long-range communications are off
everything they need to operate in a
measurable capacity is not there so they
can't send one of their guys to the far
side of the universe and maintain
contact because their rings just don't
have that ability at the moment that
entire systems offline and so because of
this they're more or less how to use
short-range investigations but
ultimately the decisions made it to have
one of their guys go out into the
universe and see if they can't figure
out what's going on now this person is
basically elected or I guess he steps
forward as Guy Gardner now again we're
gonna find out how badass Guy Gardner is
because he's actually pretty sweet in
this comic it's pretty cool but what I
want to do is I wanna get I want to jump
back to it - Hal Jordan here because I
kind of feel like the Hal Jordan of
course is one of the central characters
in this story when Sinestro learns that
Hal Jordan is going off against a couple
of the Sinestro Corps members as
immediate responses run get out of there
come back here we'll we'll marshal our
forces and then we'll take on Hal Jordan
but they basically ignore the order much
to their own to their own demise what
happens here is they decide to take them
on they believe that they have them
captured and they tell Sinestro
we have Hal Jordan captured and Sinestro
flips he says you you morons I told you
to get out of there like I told you to
leave and so because of this of course
Hal Jordan is able to break his way out
and he again continues to fight now
again this is Robert Vendetti telling us
that Hal Jordan is not a pushover Hal
Jordans not a guy that you just run over
you know that he's very formable in his
own right because he's fought so many
members of the Sinestro Corps not only
that he was taught at the need a
semester himself and so because of this
he can go to how to tell us Sinestro
that means that he could easily take on
Sinestro sworn members they don't really
stand much of a chance and so again once
this this conflict as this battle
continues on between Hal Jordan and
these members of the Sinestro Corps
ultimately we also see that a whole host
of Sinestro Corps members show up as
well in an effort to take on Hal Jordan
and effectively subdue him now because
of the fact that guy gardner has been
sent out into the universe in search of
the events that are going on to find out
what's happening right now the issue is
that he was given a 24 hour window this
was really just jon stewart operating
pragmatically right you know it was him
saying look I'm the leader of the Green
Lantern Corps right now
I've got to think of the best way to
keep this Lantern core intact because
again they're operating in isolation
here they don't know that how Jordan is
going off against the Sinestro Corps
they don't know the Sinestro Corps has
taken over as a police force of the
universe they have no idea what's been
going on so they're basically operating
on the sense of complete blindness and
so because of this you know really Jon
Stewart's kind of biding his time he's
really kind of waiting but for him it's
also the idea that not only may he lose
one of his strongest members he'll also
lose a great friend because despite the
rivalry that exists between the two of
them despite their various issues in the
past there's a massive amount of respect
between them and the reason why is
because we learn that guy gardner seems
to have these run into a couple of
members of the Sinestro Corps basically
where at least it seems as though he's
in the process of a battle and he's
being he's gonna be taken prisoner now
switching back to Hal Jordan here Hal
Jordan is easily able to take on the
rest of the Sinestro Corps without too
much effort here and this is a big deal
this is huge because again this really
hits home to the fact that Hal Jordan is
so capable in his abilities not only
that because of the fact that the
Sinestro Corps rings feed on fear it's
not just a simple situation of
empowering themselves what sinestro's
done is he's created a fear engine and
what this fear engine does is it
basically allows the Sinestro Corps
members to catch your various denizens
from around the universe take them back
hook them up to the Machine and then the
Machine feeds off their fear which in
turn powers all of the Sinestro Corps
rings and so it's basically an endless
supply of energy for the Sinestro Corps
that's not tied into parallax now what
this does or what this mystery did is it
gave Robert Venditti a way out if
parallax was going to be the source or
continue to be the source of the of the
yellow Lantern Corps it would more or
less be a situation whereby all it would
take is for parallax to be contained
defeated isolated something along those
lines but he would still live on if it
were thee if it were a fear engine
here's Robert and IDEO way to have the
Green Lantern's defeat Sinestro by
massively reducing the amount of power
that he has now again we'll get through
this or what we'll talk more about this
as we go through but for the most part a
lot of this really focuses on Hal Jordan
facing off against the Sinestro Corps
but it also focuses on the idea that
because the fear engine is powering the
Sinestro Rings that their power is being
amplified to 115 percent
one hundred and fifty percent to two
hundred percent of their normal power
but the kicker here is that Hal Jordan
has an ace up his sleeve at this point
he's transforming into pure willpower
and so it seems as though he's not
really limited by what it is that he's
capable of and or at least what it is
that a ring is normally capable of and
so because of this while he is able to
hold his own for a time the idea is that
he's ultimately not able to hold his own
against the members of the Sinestro
Corps that have so much power and so
because of this it looks as though he's
basically defeated now from here we
switch over to Sinestro himself and we
have Sinestro being presented with a
green lantern met the members of the
Sinestro Corps of capture now in a
perfect world for Sinestro this would be
Hal Jordan laying here and he would be
celebrating he would say yes we have Hal
Jordan we can basically you know we can
break his will we can control his fear
we can hook him up to the fear engine
and our power will be amplified to
levels that we can't even imagine yet
but when they show him who the Green
Lantern is is Guy Gardner now for the
Guy Gardner fans out there I'm sorry
guys
Guy Gardner is cool but he's no Hal
Jordan and I don't know if maybe this is
the message that Robert van did he was
trying to communicate but if if what he
did here came off as well it's just Guy
Gardner he's nobody to worry about he
makes up for it later on because Guy
Gardner Guy Gardner is the man Guy
Gardner is so badass now decide track
here for a quick second we're gonna jump
back to guy Gardner here the side track
for a quick second what we learned is
that house 1 was not actually defeated
well he was but he wasn't taken by the
Sinestro Corps which we know instead he
was taken by somebody else and is
presumed to be the daughter of Sinestro
who is now working against him in an
effort to basically remove him from his
position and restore the the yellow
Lantern Corps back to being a reliable
police force but jumping back to
Sinestro the idea here is that where he
believed that Hal Jordan was gonna be
brought to him the fact that his
daughter had taken Hal Jordan was
confirmed when the yellow lanterns
returned without Hal Jordan and when he
had said you guys told me you had him
captured why isn't he here they had said
well your daughter showed up and told us
that you ordered her to bring him or to
basically take him and so Sinestro says
no no no I told you to bring him here
don't listen to my daughter listen to me
and then he just kills that guy now of
course this shows us the ruthless nature
of Sinestro but more so than that it
also shows us that again
his daughter is working to to basically
subvert his control that she's working
against him as opposed to try to help
him more so than that it also tells us
that his daughter was never a true
yellow lantern now this will be
something that will be spoken about
later on but you know with it's this is
a really a passing line later and I
think right now presents the best
opportunity to have that discussion with
regards to his daughter she was very
much a member of the Green Lantern Corps
for Tom and it really seemed as though
she was best suited to the Green Lantern
becoming a yellow lantern was not her
decision she was conscripted by her
father again as part of his plan to
elevate the the Sinestro Corps to being
this police force that people celebrated
the people loved the problem with this
was that for her when it came to the
Sinestro Corps they were largely people
who were weak minded there were largely
people who relished and destruction and
creating fear and terrifying other
people those individuals who just
thrived on conflict that wasn't who she
was and so because of this while she was
a yellow lantern
she was never part and parcel to it and
so what this does is basically tells us
that her being but I guess working
against Sinestro is showing her for true
for who she truly is she's a good person
at heart and she recognizes the fact
that Sinestro her father despite the
fact that he is her father
is no fit leader for the Sinestro Corps
if the Sinestro Corps is going to
operate to take the place of the Green
Lantern's and so what we do here is we
jump back to two Guy Gardner and this is
why I say Guy Gardner is such a badass
like this this is one of the most badass
things that I've ever seen in the
history of comics and I've seen some
pretty awesome stuff so with Guy Gardner
being taken by Sinestro he was
originally given this this modicum of
power with his ring in order to ensure
life support when he was traveling
across the cosmos the problem is that
once he's actually there on war world
once he's you know held within the
confines of Sinestro's locale in their
little torture room he conjures a
construct but the power is not nearly
enough to take on Sinestro and so
because of this he drains what's left of
his power ring and he's basically just
standing around naked here but he also
starts talking trash like he did he
but like he's in a situation where he
would very much cost him his life he
could probably die and he's just talking
smack like he's literally just like
giving him hell and so because of this
like when the question is asked or when
the situation when sinestro presents the
situation and saying we're going to
break your willpower and we are going to
force you to be you know become part of
the fear engine and we're gonna force
you to tell us where the rest of the
Green Lantern Corps is he's like man
like you're that's not gonna happen no
matter what happens he refuses to break
and that's actually what happens like he
refuses to break but the way that he
refuses to break is absolutely amazing
and so what happens is we jump back to
Jon Stewart and this is really just
Robert and Diddy giving us as
all-hands-on-deck because if you guys
have noticed he's building up to this
massive conflict you have Hal Jordan
trying to find the Green Lantern's he's
been taken or not really been taken
prisoner but he's basically been rescued
by the daughter of Sinestro who's
working against her father you have Guy
Gardner who's been taken prisoner by
Sinestro but he's working against
Sinestro and then you have Jon Stewart
and the Green Lantern Corps now what Jon
Stewart says is we've got two choices
the smarter road would be to simply just
wait here to be would be to just stay
here on the edge of the universe when no
one knows we're at and to wait to see if
Guy Gardner returns the problem with
this is that it's very possible that Guy
Gardner has been captured and if he has
been captured then he's probably not
gonna come back not only that if he's
being tortured being held prisoner they
may kill him in which case if we do
nothing we might as well have killed him
ourselves
so he says either we can stay here and
do nothing or we can go find Guy Gardner
we can make our presence known to the
universe and we can do whatever we need
to do but because they're Green
Lantern's and this is why this is so
badass because they're Green Lantern's
they're like we don't sit around we
don't rest on our laurels whether it's
whether we win or whether we all die
we're gonna go find Guy Gardner and
we're gonna do our damnedest to rescue
him so what we do god this is so badass
so what we do is we jump to Guy Gardner
all right and Guy Gardner is being
interrogated he's literally being
tortured but he won't talk he won't tell
them where the Green Lantern Corps is
not only that
not only that there's this amazing line
that he says were the guys torturing him
he says you better put your back into a
cupcake what an awesome thing to say
what an awesome line but the really cool
thing here is that when that when the
torturer begins a process of basically
saying fine we're going to enhance the
torture we're going to make it worse for
you guy Gardner starts running off the
Green Lantern oath not only that he'll
keep doing that like and it's it's so
cool because for me Guy Gardner always
seemed like the jokester right he always
seemed like the guy that no one took
seriously he was a frat boy in the Green
Lantern Corps in a lot of ways he was
but what Robert VIN did he's telling us
here and I'm sure has been previously
established in Geoff Johns run is that
yeah Guy Gardner is a joker Guy Gardner
silly Guy Gardner is nonsensical from
time to time buddy's got it where it
counts and that is so awesome that's
really cool here and so what we do is
again we basically pick up with Hal
Jordan speaking with the daughter of
Sinestro and what happens your issue
basically says I use some of the yellow
power fear - more or less to fix you up
but she also notices that he crafted his
own ring because it's not the same kind
of design that all the other Green
Lantern's have and the question is how
did you do this where did this ring come
from how is this possible and he simply
says I made it myself I put it together
myself not only that he also tells her
that he seems to be coming one with with
willpower in and of itself his body or
his structure it seems to be changing
and so again we're not really given a
whole lot of information here in terms
of what this means the indication is
that because he's becoming one with
willpower he is becoming willpower
itself he is becoming literally a living
construct but we don't know that for
absolute certainty all we really know
here is that his powers seem to be
moving in a new direction moving into a
new echelon and so switching back to Jon
Stewart and the Green Lantern Corps and
what we find here is that while they're
transitioning across the cosmos while
they're traveling to whatever it is or
whatever direction it was that guy
Gardner went in there suddenly met upon
by a host of ships and the ships that
they all meet and initially seem to
possibly be enemies and they take on
defensive formations but what happens is
we learn that there's there's actually a
little bit more going
on here that with sinestro going through
with his core going through inflicting
fear terrifying people kidnapping them
and hooking them up to the fear engine
that not everyone is okay with this not
only that the a lot of people a lot of
the citizens in the universe they're not
cowards that they're basically
marshalling their forces as best they
can and eventually with their forces
marshaled they intend to wage a war
against Sinestro now we know that
suicide we know that if these guys these
various alien races were to try to take
on the entirety of the Sinestro Corps
especially with the Sinestro Corps power
being bolstered by virtue of the sphere
engine that it would it would lead to
the complete and utter ruin but when in
meeting the Green Lantern's they
basically come to a reconciliation these
guys say hey look the Sinestro Corps is
gone crazy they're taking over the
universe and Jon Stewart says well we're
trying to find our guy guy Gardner uh
have you seen him they say no and they
say okay fine well let's just rally our
forces we'll deal with the Sinestro
Corps while we try to find guy Gardner
and so one of the other interesting
things here this is something that I
that I hope you guys like is for I hope
you guys notice is that with the Green
Lantern's there they haven't been
forgotten people still know who they are
well there are a lot of people in the
new generation of alien races that were
born relatively recently who hearkened
to the Sinestro Corps and say yeah there
there are there are saviors and they
don't their planet hasn't been attacked
yet they don't realize what the Sinestro
Corps is doing for the old guard they
remember back to the days when the Green
Lantern's were the true protectors of
the universe and that while the Green
Lantern's may have engaged in conflicts
that laid waste to planets and while the
Green Lantern's may have in and of
themselves some members turned evil the
fact remains that the Green Lantern's
were always a force for good they were
always there to protect the universe as
best they could even if there was
collateral damage and so this seems to
be the old guard or at the very least
those who remember the way things were
before that the Green Lantern's existed
to protect people and so by joining
forces it allows the various weapons of
these these these armies to work in
conjunction with the construct abilities
of the Green Lantern's and in turn
percent a pretty formidable army or at
the very least it bolsters their ranks
and so again what we do here is we pick
up with Hal Jordan now what Hal Jordan
had done during the
half of his conversation with the
daughter of Sinestro as he had said look
like I know I have a whole new set of
abilities now I know I'm more powerful
than I was before here's what's gonna
happen I am going to go to the home base
of Sinestro and I'm gonna defeat him but
when I get there there's going to be a
lot of damage because I'm going to
destroy war world so if you have anybody
on that planet that you care about
anybody on that planet that you think
will fight for our side then you need to
get them out of there and in fact that's
what she says she says hey look not
everybody who's part of the Sinestro
Corps believes in the Sinestro Corps you
know there are people who are part of
the Sinestro Corps that are there
because it's better to be on the devil's
right hand than in his path but it
doesn't mean that they agree with what
they're doing and so what she says this
week if we give them a chance to stand
up and fight against Sinestro they will
do that they will literally fight from
within it will create a civil war within
the Sinestro Corps and so how toward and
says fine go do that Marshall those
forces and when I get there we'll all
take on Sinestro together now again
something to keep in mind is that Hal
Jordan does not know about the rest of
the Green Lantern Corps a doesn't know
about Guy Gardner so in his mind he's
going into this conflict with the power
that he possesses using his newfound
connection with willpower and whatever
forces the daughter of Sinestro can
marshal to their side that's what he
knows is really coming there but this
also gives us some perspective of Hal
Jordan views himself with regards to his
new power if he's willing to go headlong
into a battle against the Sinestro Corps
did it means one of two things it means
either he realizes how powerful he is or
he's batshit crazy but we know that it
means that he knows how powerful he is
now and so again what happens and this
is something that's really funny here is
what happens is we transition back to
Guy Gardner again because Guy Gardner
got Gardner I Love You Man so we
transitioned back to guy Gardner again
and with the the chronicler slash you
know concubine of Sinestro showing up
basically saying we need to speed up
this torture of of Guy Gardner Guy
Gardner hits on her he says he says
somebody needs to call the police
because the way you look is killing me
which is hilarious to me and so of
course it's just guy Gardner being silly
but it's also guy Gardner setting a
standard this is Guy Gardner saying like
you're not gonna get me to talk I'm so
sure
you can't get me to talk that I'm gonna
crack jokes and I'm gonna be silly and
so what what this woman says what Lysa
says is she's basically speaking with
you know the interrogator and she says
look in an attack is coming there's
going to be an assault on war world how
Jordan is coming to fight us this is the
first time that Guy Gardner realizes
that Hal Jordan is now back to being a
Green Lantern again that Hal Jordan is
back that Hal Jordan is launching a
campaign to attack Sinestro now this is
very very important and the reason why
is because this gives Guy Gardner
renewed hope and that's one of the most
important things when it comes to the
Green Lantern mythos yes the Green
Lantern's reside on will the will power
will power is the source of their
strength and their ability but willpower
is useless if you don't believe that
things will get better if you can't hope
that things will get better that's one
of the reasons why the blue lanterns of
hope are such an intricate part of the
Green Lantern mythos of course I believe
at this point the blue lanterns have all
been wiped out but the fact remains here
that hope is a very powerful thing
because it leads you to believe that
things can get better and this is
exactly what happens with the guy
Gardiner while Hal Jordan is launching
his campaign while he's taking on almost
the entirety of the Sinestro Corps what
Sinestro himself is doing is marshalling
his own abilities and this is so sweet
because I don't think I've ever seen
anything like this before now again I'm
not as well-versed in the Green Lantern
mythos as I imagined a lot of you all
are but I've never really seen anything
like this before
Sinestro starts marshalling the power
available to him you know absorbing the
power of the fear engine to the point
that he boosts his ring to a thousand
percent power level that is insane and
so what this seems to be doing or at
least what this seems to happen with
regards to what rubber Venditti is
telling us is that Sinestro and Hal
Jordan seem to be even not only that I
think it also gives us a perspective of
what Hal Jordans capable of in the sense
that you know with with Sinestro
marshaling his power to the point that
his ring is 1,000% above its normal
capacity its normal charge of 100 in
charge that with Hal Jordan going
against him and still being able to hold
his own it tells us that whatever this
power is that withheld Rijn becoming a
living construct that his power is equal
to about a thousand percent of a normal
power ring and so it's insane the kind
of level that the kind of energy that he
possesses now really the fault of
Sinestro here is he sits down and he
says look like Hal Jordan you've
constantly been a thorn in my side since
I first met you you've been nothing but
a let down but in truth this has never
been the case Hal Jordan has always been
one of the best of the Green Lantern's
the reason why Sinestro says this is
partly because I would imagine Sinestro
can't admit to himself that Hal Jordan
may very well be greater than he is
there's a huge debate that goes on in
the Green Lantern fan base who's better
Sinestro or how Jordan and I'm not even
I'm not even gonna touch that if I could
post a comment I want to know who you
guys think is better Hal Jordan or
Sinestro if if anybody's gonna get
screamed out that you screamed out for
that ain't gonna be me ask you guys we
got to scream at each other I'm not even
gonna poke that bowl but the fact
remains that this basically brings in
the entire history of the two of them
and what I mean here is ever since again
you know how's werden first became a
Green Lantern ever since he was chosen
by the ring of Abin sword and ever since
he first became first crossed as a
Sinestro and was taught how to be a
Green Lantern there's always been this
rivalry the two of them have fought over
the years the two of them have been
allies over the years but the fact
remains there's always been this
animosity between the two and what
Robert Venditti seems to be doing is
basically giving us this creme de la
creme of conflicts this sort of
end-all-be-all Grand Poobah Hal Jordan
versus Sinestro title fight 15 rounds
battle and the great thing about this is
that it seems to be the height of their
powers I mean like this shot right here
of Hal Jordan and Sinestro chest out
fighting each other is amazing because
you have Sinestro at 1,000% normal power
and you have Hal Jordan who for all
intents and purposes is becoming a
living construct these at least at this
moment right now seem to be the two most
powerful lanterns in existence and so it
seems to be this quintessential question
of what happens when an unstoppable
force meets an immovable object and so
what happens is we transition here back
to guy garden this is why I say the
power of hope is such a huge thing
knowing that Hal Jordan is out there
fighting even if he's only fighting
alone knowing that Hal Jordan is out
there and doing his best to protect the
universe as best he can allows not
my gardener to marshal his own abilities
to marshal his own strength of character
but it'll it influences everybody else
around him this shows us the power of
the Green Lantern's not just in creating
physical constructs not just in you know
being able to fly and engage in really
cool battles of stuff it shows us the
power of the Green Lantern's in the
hearts and minds of the universe's
citizens because he starts running off
the Green Lantern oath in brightest day
in blackest night and everybody else
starts reciting it as well you know no
evil shall escape their mind let those
who worship evils might beware their
power Green Lantern's light and
everybody says in everyone who's hooked
up to the fear engine says it every
single person and because of this their
willpower is able to fight off fear and
because it's able to fight off fear the
fear engine is no longer able to
manipulate their minds and it basically
begins reducing the power of the
Sinestro Corps it reduces the power of
of Sinestro himself and so because of
this because his power begins to drop
off it's effectively inevitable that
semester was going to be defeated now
ultimately this also leads to Guy
Gardner marshalling the rest of the
Sinestro Corps members who are avidly
standing against Sinestro fighting on
behalf of what remains of the Green
Lantern Corps or at the very least
living up to their previous positions
but because of the power that that Hal
Jordan possesses here because of his
capabilities and basically being a
living construct Sinestro doesn't
realize what's going on an initially
Sinestro says stop you have to stop this
because at this point Sinestro I think
begins to realize what Hal Jordan is now
that Hal Jordans not just a Green
Lantern guys he's not just a guy running
around with a power ring that Hal Jordan
is now becoming a living construct his
power Dwarfs that of Sinestro in
addition Sinestro is faced with his own
mortality and this comes to fruition
when Hal Jordan lets off all the energy
that he possesses when he lets off all
this power that he has and in doing so
destroys war world and seems to kill
Sinestro in the process now I wouldn't
swear that as being an absolute truth
but it seems as though he's killed
Sinestro and so in a little bit of humor
here and a little bit of humor with
Robert Van Diddy still has John Stewart
and the Green Lantern Corps heading
going headlong into the conflict but
it's already done
it's already over they don't even get to
fight which is the saddest thing ever
but they are met by the arrival I guess
as a story comes to an end they are met
by the arrival of Guy Gardner who's
being protected by you know of course
the daughter of Sinestro with a power
ring as well as those members of the
Sinestro Corps who worked against
Sinestro and who are now a lying
themselves with the Green Lantern Corps
itself okay so I held on as long as I
could but reading the new Green
Lantern's story basically training day
is what it is like the whole training
story with seven Bad's and Jessica Cruz
we have to start going over Hal Jordan
and the Green Lantern so now we already
did Sinestro slaw which is the opening
story for Hal Jordan in the Green
Lantern's rubber van Diddy
you are an amazing guy okay check us out
- you're never gonna believe this story
so so we're in Chicago for c2e2
myself and Vinny a comics trainer
hanging out with Robert Venditti we were
talking about something I can't what it
was no I was trying to convince him to
tell me something that happens in Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern's in event that
seems like it's leading in Watchmen and
he wouldn't tell me what it was and so
he was like aren't you the guy that got
on Twitter and was like hey everybody
like what's your favorite story from DC
rebirth and why is it Superman and I was
like no man I was it was pretty funny
he's a really really cool guy he's
really fun to hang out with but uh but
anyway so with regards to Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern's what we saw the first
storyline was the de facto death of Hal
Jordan now Sinestro also seemed to have
died too but we don't really know what
happened to him and in fact here we
really focus on we focus on Hal Jordan
now the cool thing is that for those of
you guys who are keeping up with my
videos on Geoff Johns Green Lantern run
a lot of the stuff that we're going over
will start to become more and more
familiar to you the more we cover Geoff
Johns run so it's kind of cool here for
example the daughter of Sinestro is the
one running the Sinestro Corps now so
those are the kind of things that we
start to get into the kind of things
that begin to make sense to you guys so
again it's really kind of a self
fulfilling thing now those of you guys
who are watching my you're Geoff Johns
Green Lantern videos what we're gonna do
is we're gonna throw this in to the
Geoff Johns video but we're constantly
gonna bump these back as we put in new
information so these will always be at
the very end until we begin to you know
sort of fill out and so on and so forth
but the fact remains here with the end
of Hal Jordan and the Green Lanterns
said Astros law we kind of saw something
that we'd never really seen before what
we ended up getting was basically how
Jordan's ring which was made completely
by him now we'll talk about that here in
a second but of course what we also do
is we have you know Jon Stewart who's
basically leading the Green Lantern
Corps and the daughter of Sinestro who's
leading the Sinestro Corps and what
they've done is essentially come
together because remember at the end of
really kind of going into the new 52 at
the tail end of geoff johns run and
picking out with robert van Betty's run
we basically had this whole scenario
where the guardians of the universe were
almost completely and totally
obliterated with the exception of
ganthet and sayd they were just kind of
exiled out into the middle of nowhere
they've been gone the entire time Jon
Stewart and the other Green Lantern's
we're essentially kind of OWL stood
beyond all known existence and kind of
taken all the way back to the very
beginning of the universes origin and
what it did is it set the stage for the
Sinestro Corps to basically have run of
the land they could essentially
implement their own law
you know operating under the guise of
being protectors and then force the
universe into enslavement of course this
basically resulted in the Green
Lantern's kind of coming back or at
least it was a very coincidental timely
thing they came back they fought against
the the Sinestro Corps and Sinestro
supposedly died and so because of that
we basically have these two cores
operating together the issue is that
despite the fact that really kind of in
shambles so they're really just kind of
hanging on by the skin of their teeth at
the end of the day they are Green
Lantern's and they are the universe's
police force and so they grab what
numbers they have they grab the Sinestro
Corps and they take off to sector two
eight one three which is basically the
whole Vegas sector for the purpose of
responding to a threat now of course we
end up finding out this threat comes in
the form of Starro now this is a great
throwback this is a really really cool
throwback Starro is a filler villain
right
Starro is the guy you bring in when
you're launching a new story and you
want to show what the team is about a
star was the original villain of the
Justice League of America when they were
first created in 1960 he's a very first
villain to the Justice League and he
really kind of has a special place to
the legacy of DC Comics because of that
so he's like the guy that's been at the
job for like thirty years and now he
just doesn't ever do anything but nobody
fires him because he's paid his dues
it's really kind of what happens with
star over here I mean if he's the guy on
the couch more or less you know and it's
it's things like this I think it's
really you know these these small little
moments these these little great things
that make how
and the Green Lanterns the best thing
come out of DC rebirth because it's just
these great little tidbits of history
that gets thrown and get kind of brought
into this story now of course with star
au effectively vanishing you know
essentially disappearing one is up
happening is the Green Lanterns you know
essentially try to chase after him only
to find out that they've been contained
and they're held inside one of the jars
of Brainiac now this is really kind of
cool because again
brainiacs big claim to fame is that he
just goes around putting things in
containers now we know from our our
injustice injustice origin videos for
Brainiac because we basically described
the new 52 origin which you'll find down
in the description we know a lot of this
was rooted in the idea that he was
basically trying to save the universe or
save you know all things of existence
from a warring race outside of you know
from another dimension but the fact
remains here that his big thing is just
traveling around the cosmos grabbing
things that are interesting bottling
them up and then just holding them in
place and so effectively the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps are
stuck inside a giant jar as is being
held by Brainiac which is kind of cool
but again picking up with Hal Jordans
Green Lantern ring we end up finding out
that after he died the ring eventually
sought out ganthet and sayd now the
reason why this matters is because of
the fact that Green Lantern rings do not
do this remember ganthet aside have just
kind of been outside of everything they
really have no idea what's been going on
for the most part I mean they have a
general idea they have a general
understanding but to their knowledge
they didn't know that Howard's Wooden
was dead not only that they didn't know
that how Jordan forged his own ring
under normal circumstances in the Green
Lantern mythos say for example there's
you know sector 2 8 1 4 which is the
location of earth in the in the DC
universe what usually ends up happening
is the Green Lantern will die and then
it'll say ok Green Lantern of sector to
8 1 4 is dead searching out a new
Lantern and it'll immediately just hunt
down a brand new Lantern that person
will be selected they'll be told you
know you have the a power to overcome
great fear they will be selected to
become a Green Lantern and they'll be
whisked off to what would normally be OA
the base of operations for the for the
Green Lantern's right now simogo the
giant Green Lantern planet but they'll
be whisked off in order to go through
the training process and be brought in
to you know to being a Green Lantern the
difference here is that this ring is
explicitly looking for Hal Jordan and
that has never happened before it's one
of the coolest things to take place and
the whole Green Lantern landscape and so
what we're gonna do here it's for the
most part the whole events with you know
the
conflict with the Green Lanterns is
really just kind of them facing off
against you know star oh and the little
mini stars these used to basically take
over the minds of different people
that's not wildly important I mean it's
it's there and it's something to be read
but what Robert Vendetti is really doing
here is emphasizing Hal Jordan it's
really kind of like the Green Lantern's
are a secondary plot to what's going on
with Hal with regards to his ring
searching explicitly for him what we end
up doing is we actually pick up with him
in the afterlife now he gets these
little glimpses and different things
like that and it's kind of cool to see
this because it's kind of been Diddy
taking his own stance on what happens
when a person dies and it's been
depicted different ways over the course
of DC Comics publication history but
here it's almost like an afterlife
explicitly for the Green Lantern's and
that's not unheard of I mean the
speedforce is the afterlife for the
flashes for speedsters of the DC
Universe and Marvel Comics people from
Asgard who died honorably they go to
hala again like there's a lot of
different things that go on with regards
to how it is that death is depicted in
comic books and it's always kind of cool
to see you know an individual's own
depiction on the realm of death but in
his journey Hal Jordan basically comes
across a dancer now this again is a
really great moment of history here
because that's what this is designed to
be how Jordan the Green Lantern's is
designed to pay so much homage to all
the work that was done both by friend
Eddie himself and by Geoff Johns and so
the idea is to basically give us a lot
of these great little hallmark moments
and of course essentially with what
appears to be the defeat of Starro you
know the various little mini star oohs
kind of fall off the faces that people
who have been captured and so on and so
forth and again we're just kind of
touching back on that a little bit of a
conflict here and there so you guys can
sort of understand what's going on but
the fact remains speaking directly with
AB and Sewer what seems to be happening
is avin soar is effectively easing Hal
Jordans passing now this is really kind
of cool and it seems like something that
you would expect right I mean I don't
really think about death very often you
know but I have thought about scenarios
what would happen when the time comes
where I pass on and I always thought it
would be kind of a cool idea
if you encounter someone who kind of
takes you on this journey who takes you
on this path that helps to ease the
transition between your living and the
fact that you're in the afterlife now
because I imagine to be a pretty jarring
experience to suddenly just be dead well
that's that you know and there's gotta
be whisked away you know to some place
or something one of those lines but the
fact remains here you know with with
regards to Evans
the whole idea of kind of easing Hal
Jordan is passing also comes with the
notion that Hal Jordan shouldn't be here
and that's what's kind of crazy is
because of all the people that could
have appeared to Hal Jordan it's a
bandsaw and so while he's kind of here
to say hey look man like you're in the
afterlife just so you know you basically
died you know the idea is to say look
man right now is not your time you are
not supposed to be dead you are supposed
to be alive now this doesn't mean that
Evans Sewer can see the future you know
it doesn't mean that he's you know a guy
that knows everything that's gonna
happen later on down the line what it
does mean is that how Jordans gonna play
a very intrinsic part and the events to
come because keep in mind everything in
DC Comics is leading up to you know the
whole reveal of the Watchmen and all
that kind of good stuff and that's
really what's going on right now and you
know the Green Lantern's by Sam
Humphreys you know the reason why we're
kind of going back and covering all this
stuff is because we basically have the
Green Lantern Simon Baz and Jessica
Crews showing up to receive training
alongside Guy Gardner and Kyle Rayner
and so they're basically going to step
into the role of being tried and true
Green Lantern's because all these
numbers are being consolidated all these
different superhero teams are being
brought together armies are being raised
all these preparations for war are being
made with regards to the DC landscape if
you look that's exactly what's happening
Superman's consolidated with his new 52
power and he's stronger than he ever was
all the Green Lantern's are being
recalled back to OA you have all these
different things taking place especially
with the button I'm not gonna spoil
anything cuz it just came out and its
really really good but all these things
are taking place for the purpose of
consolidating numbers and so what is up
happening is ganthet and sayd basically
reach out and they yank Kyle Lena they
bring Kyle Rayner over to the location I
keep him on Kyle Rayner is the White
Lantern and so he can literally reach
into the afterlife and pull Hal Jordan
out but the crazy thing is that s is
depicted here it's contingent on the
mindset of the person who's already
there and so how Jordan is in a very
confused state he doesn't know what's
going on I mean he's being told yes you
know this is this is not your time you
are not supposed to pass on yet but for
him he's also kind of accepting to a
degree I mean he's like you know I don't
really know where I am but he's not
panicking
he's not freaking out it's nothing like
that you know it's him basically just
kind of like yeah I guess maybe this is
the afterlife you know he's calm he's
relaxed he's not panicking and clamoring
his way back to life again and so
because of that where he does meet all
these other members of the Green
Lantern's who have died you know
moire and in all these various
individuals and it is really cool to see
if the fact remains here the car Raider
essentially uses his power reaches into
the ring that is Hal Jordans and tries
to bring him back now that's the cool
thing because the ring is what anchors
Hal Jordan to the possibility of
continuing to live the ring is what
angers him that it's almost as if you
know for example you had fallen down
into a hole and you were just holding on
to the edge somebody can grab your hand
and they can pull you back up and that's
exactly what Kyle Rayner is doing with
Hal Jordans rain hat Hal Jordan not
forged this ring out of his willpower
all of his essence would essentially be
gone with him because this is again just
a small essence of what Hal Jordan is it
allows Kyle Rayner to reach in to the
ring itself and pull Hal Jordan out and
that's exactly what he does and that's
one of the coolest things to see is him
basically resurrecting Hal Jordan
bringing Hal Jordan back now of course
once Hal Jordan is here we also end up
finding out that where Brainiac is going
around and gathering up all these
different artifacts and putting them in
containers that while this is a normal
trend of Brainiac Brainiac himself is
actually being controlled by Larfleeze
now there are Green Lantern fans out
there who love Larfleeze they're like
yes Larfleeze in other people who have
Larfleeze he's got so much character
he's such a cool character so here's the
deal
Larfleeze taps into the to the emotional
spectrum of avarice oh really the
emotion of avarice in the emotional
spectrum ie
greed he is the greediest lantern hello
in the universe it's such a cool concept
too because if you're the Green Lantern
that taps into the emotion of greed you
would be the only Lantern right I mean
if you were the the orange lantern
rather that happened to the emotional
spectrum of greed you'd be the only
Lantern and he is he keeps his central
powder or he keeps his a power battery
and close check his central power
battery is in close check everything
that he values is just kind of hoarded
because that's what he is he's a hoarder
he's a he's a guy that just hoard stuff
but the other half of this is the orange
Lantern Corps there is no orange Lantern
Corps per se someone because of the fact
that Larfleeze keeps himself is the only
one with an orange Lantern ring instead
what he does is those individuals that
he kills he in turn makes constructs out
of he effectively captures their essence
and makes them into constructs so it's
really kind of a twist
did scenario and it would be a fate
worse than death to be taken by
Larfleeze but what he ended up doing was
basically stumbling across one of the
old designs of the old bills builds of
Brainiac now in truth when did he give
this kind of get away with this to be
honest I mean there's been so many
versions of brainiacs that have appeared
over the years as so many versions that
have been defeated we would kind of have
to believe that some older models some
obsolete version of Brainiac it's just
kind of laying in a junk heap somewhere
in the universe I mean it just makes
sense I mean it really just kind of
makes good sense with this character but
what is up happening is because of the
fact that Brainiac exists to basically
capture catalog and store objects
Larfleeze tapes Brainiac makes him his
own and the two of them just begin going
around for the purpose of capturing
artifacts for Larfleeze to just hoard
things so that's kind of a cool idea
it's a cool blending of like-minded
things in this sense that Brainiac does
exactly what Larfleeze does the only
difference is that Brainiac doesn't have
a Lantern ring which seeing Brainiac
with a Lantern moon would be kind of
cool but again brainiacs just kind of
serving his purpose here and so of
course with Hal Jordan having been dead
or at least you know having died without
having been aware of the fact that Jon
Stewart and the other lanterns had
arrived with Kyle Weiner being there and
kind of having been this Shepherd
throughout the universe really kind of
helping worlds thrive and grow and so on
he basically tells how Jordan look the
Green Lantern Corps is back and so how
George immediately races off alongside a
Kyle Rayner and ganthet is say now
remember with regards to the to the
return of the Green Lantern's I wouldn't
go as far as to say that it's like
ganthet and sayd basically saying yeah
things are gonna be just like they were
before it's not gonna be like that it's
not gonna be that way but what it will
do is it will offer a return to normalcy
and the reason why is because of the
fact that when almost all the guardians
of the universe were completely
destroyed by Sinestro who was possessed
by the parallax entity at the time what
he did is he left ganthet and sayd a lot
it's basically allowing them to
experience emotions guilt remorse dimmer
things like that shame for the different
actions they've been involved in over
the course of their time as guardians of
the universe and allowed them to stay in
isolation
returning back you know with the
Reformation of the Green Lantern's means
the ganthet and sayd can bring those
experiences with them they can kind of
walk away from this idea that emotion is
a weakness and instead see it for what
it is something that could help to make
more rational decisions than if they
were emotionless now of course again
this really kind of begs the question on
you know which one was better whether
they had emotions or when they
have emotions and in fact only time will
tell with regards to this story but the
fact remains here you know with Hal
Jordan with Kyle Rayner with ganthet say
basically showing up - Mogo mogul
basically says look yes they're using me
as a base of operations
they were recalled to another sector to
deal with a conflict and then all
communications basically vanished now
it's just the search is on for the Green
Lantern Corps the search is on to
basically find them and the Sinestro
Corps now again how Jordan does not know
that the Green Lantern Corps and the
Sinestro Corps have joined forces he's
not aware of that in his mind
there's just the Green Lantern Corps now
from here what we actually have is a
really really good instance of Jon
Stewart showing his chops when it comes
to being a good leader and this is one
of the reasons why I really think that
it's high time that Jon Stewart got his
time in the Sun because I think then did
he's doing a great job with regards to
his character because the job stewart
effectively leading everything you get
to see how capable he is now in truth
under Jeff Jones you know all the
lanterns of Earth got their Tom and they
really got their time in the Sun they
got a chance to for us as the reader to
experience them but I think that in
terms of Jon Stewart being a tried and
true leader of the Green Lantern's I
don't really think that edge of oblivion
showed that for what it was so I don't
think it really showed him you know for
being capable of a leader as he is
especially now that he has to work
alongside basically his sworn enemy the
Sinestro Corps and so what Jon Stewart
basically says is look I know Larfleeze
I know what he's about Larfleeze Prizes
his possessions Larfleeze
only cares about the objects that he has
if he begins losing those he'll do
almost anything to get them back he'll
just snatch things up he'll do whatever
it is that he has to and so what Jon
Stewart says is our plan should be to
work alongside each other and basically
fight each other now again this is
really kind of cool because we in turn
have the Brainiac Android feeding on
this the Brainiac Android basically says
look man like they're gonna they're
gonna go against each other and they are
gonna lead to their destruction but
here's the deal you can catalogue all
different kinds of events I mean some of
these things are irreplaceable some of
these things simply cannot be stopped
you can't bring them back you just don't
have the power to do that and so at the
risk of losing the Sinestro Corps
entirely or losing the Green Lantern
Corps in its entirety but Larfleeze
basically lashes out and destroys the
bottle in which they're held which of
course leads to them lissa the Sinestro
Corps and the Green Lantern Corps
fighting against the constructs of
Larfleeze now you know with Hal Jordan
stepping in you know how Jordan arriving
Kyle Rayner arriving for a lot of fans
this was a return to the familiarity
they've been looking for for so long we
would get this great full-page slash of
Jon Stewart and and Kyle Rayner and Hal
Jordan and Guy Gardner the four top
Green Lantern's of Earth and a lot of
fans really kind of looked at this and
said this is the Green Lantern's these
are the Green Lantern's that I know the
Green Lantern's I grew up with the Green
Lantern's that I loved and Venditti did
not do this by accident this was not an
accidental thing these four for the most
part are D Green Lantern's they
alongside all the other respective fans
of these Green Lantern's will say they
are the top
lanterns now a crowd is growing for
Jessica Cruz and a crowd is growing for
for some and bass and this is most
certainly being helped by Sam Humphreys
amazing writing and the Green Lantern
stories but in terms of the lanterns as
we know them those are the ones that
they think of those are the ones that
they believed to be the top lanterns now
of course this also leads directly into
the the Green Lantern Corps and the
Sinestro Corps merging into a singular
Corps again how Jordan is still pretty
new to all this really hasn't had a
whole lot of time to ask questions and
to figure out what's going on and said
we just kind of get a singular Lantern
core which is really gonna be kind of
cool but what this does is this
basically leads into the return of Saint
Walker the blue lantern somebody
understand that somebody is gonna
explain this to me why do you guys like
st. Walker's so much and please don't
say because he's awesome that doesn't
answer anything I want to know why st.
Walker is so cool why do people love him
it's a cool name Saint Walker is an
awesome name but people love Saint
Walker and I just don't understand why
okay so getting into a Hal Jordan and
the Green Lantern Corps the quest for
hope the funny thing about this is that
I accidentally deleted this recording
like I had this already done and
everything and then accident deleted it
and I was like no because I tried all my
recovery software in order to get it
back and I couldn't find it and I was
like oh my god so I've got to go back
and rerecord it but the cool thing is
that this is kind of par for the course
like I usually record audio as a couple
of times to make sure that I get all the
points across you know that I want to
make but for those of you guys who are
new to the Green Lantern landscape the
way that DC we Worth has done Green
Lantern is in two different ways
we have Green Lantern's rebirth which is
basically the new fans
two green lanterns you literally learn
about the Green Lantern mythos as
assignment baths and Jessica Cruz learn
about it then there's Hal Jordan and the
Green Lantern Court and that's more for
established things all it really did
when greenly I guess when Hal Jordan and
the Green Lantern Corps rebirth kicked
off is it continued a lot of the stories
that had just kind of had dangling plot
threads at the end of geoff johns run
going into robert van de DS run and so
that was a goal to basically wrap those
things up and so what happened is robert
van diddy began the process of writing
his own stories of basically saying
here's everything that i'm creating for
the very first time and it's really
really cool because it comes together
almost seamlessly you could just follow
the entire story because again Green
Lantern as it stands right now is this
massive ten years long worth of just
events it's just this massive cosmology
but the idea here is that this initially
picks up with a guy named space caddy
now the funny thing about this is it
space caddy is not news space caddy has
been around for a long time but this
fits directly in line with the nature of
DC rebirth which is to say that we're
basically talking about this point where
DC is grabbing characters that had been
around for a very long time whether they
were obscure whether they were really
popular and basically either updating
them or keeping them the same if they
were that familiar for example Wally
West the classic flash came back and
he's basically the same when it comes to
a character like space cabby he's about
as obscure as it gets this guy first
popped up back in 1954 with mystery and
space number 21 I think it was I want to
say he was an auto bender creation but
I'm not gonna swear to that but the idea
was that space cabby is exactly what he
sounds like he's a guy that ferries
people across the universe now DC kind
of delves into these things periodically
and it's really just designed to kind of
bolster the cosmic landscape of DC
Comics that was the original purpose of
space cabby and that's the purpose he
serves now for the most part whenever it
comes to the cosmos Green Lantern is
about as extensive as a gift we don't
really see a whole lot of other stories
out there that deal with like the cosmic
landscape of DC don't like marvel marvel
you'll read guardians of the galaxy
you'll read Captain Marvel depending on
who's riding it you can read fan OHS
you'll get this huge well-rounded space
you know exploration and in fact the
spacefaring escapades of the various
characters that exist out there are
usually done just as much as the
earth-based events so you're just as
likely to see a story of Captain America
fighting the Red Skull as you are to see
I was trying you know fighting against
Galactus and like overpowering him which
he did and it was an amazing story but
the idea here is that space cabby was a
guy who's basically done everything I
mean he's been a soldier of fortune he's
just been a ferryman he's done all kinds
of stuff he lends his abilities to the
highest bidder
the reason why he's in this story is
because this ties in to the existing
events that are going on in Hal Jordan
and the Green Lantern Corps if you're
just now joining the events what
effectively had happened is that we had
basically Sinestro and Hal Jordan
fighting one another for what was
believed to be the last time that was
the idea they've been enemies for so
long BC rebirth was designed to kind of
make a return to familiarity but also
begin moving things in a different
direction and the whole Sinestro as a
backdrop a villain - Hal Jordan had been
going on for decades and decades and
decades and so it made sense that DC
would come along and say let's go ahead
and back off and let's try something new
and so in the very first story arc of
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps
called Sinestro's law Hal Jordan and
Sinestro fought and they were both
basically killed now the idea is that
following the death of Sinestro his
daughter cirrhotic took up his mantle
now if you're following our Green
Lantern videos on Sunday which is when
we covered all the classic Green Lantern
stuff that leads into DC rebirth what we
know is it's erotic as the daughter of
Sinestro was originally a member of the
Green Lantern Corps the issue is that
eventually she became a member of the
Sinestro Corps but during Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern rebirth with the death of
Sinestro she took up her father's mantle
but instead of being a bad guy what she
did is she worked directly alongside Jon
Stewart and brought the Green Lantern's
and the Sinestro Corps together now with
regards to the Green Lantern's
themselves this again fits in to a lot
of the stuff that was leading in to DC
rebirth what had happened is that there
was basically a story called edge of
oblivion I think it was and it was
essentially the Green Lantern's just
kind of being catapulted or at least
what was left to the Green Lantern's
being catapulted all the way back to the
very beginning of the universe and the
result was that in the present day there
were no Green Lantern's the result was
that Sinestro saw as his chance to
basically take the Sinestro Corps have
it masquerade as a peacekeeping force
all for the purpose of basically
building on people believing in them the
idea was that once people who looked to
the Sinestro Corps as their protectors
Sinestro would betray them he would
instill fear and then conquer the
universe
but all that basically came to a head
during Hal Jordan the Green Lantern
Corps rebirth with Sinestro's law and so
it
and what this means is that at this
point in the story we basically have a
strange situation you have basically a
lot of the members of the Sinestro Corps
who despise the Green Lantern's and
you've got a lot of members of the Green
Lantern's who despise the Sinestro Corps
because they've been fighting for so
long remember when the Sinestro Corps
first showed up and again I have
Sinestro Corps war down in the
description you're welcome to check it
out when the Sinestro Corps first popped
up they started slaughtering Green
Lantern's everywhere they saw them it
was an absolute bloodbath it wasn't
until they got to the point where it
looked like Sinestro was going to win
that the guardians of the universe
adjusted the laws of the Rings allowing
Green Lantern's to kill members of the
Sinestro Corps that turned the tide and
the Green Lantern's ended up winning the
war or at least they basically defeated
the Sinestro Corps but the idea is that
following the defeat of Sinestro and all
this kind of stuff that's going on right
now what this basically means is that
the Green Lantern's and the Sinestro
Corps have a very tenuous relationship
to say the least but in that first story
arc with the death of Hal Jordan what we
found out was a Kyle Rayner as the white
Lantern had essentially resurrected him
now remember as the white lantern Kyle
Rayner has mastery over all the rings he
can do anything I mean he's basically
God in DC's universe and that's
something that I want you to keep in
mind for a second because once we get to
the end of this video it's really gonna
showcase just how powerful dr. Manhattan
is but the idea here is that with Hal
Jordan having died because he was kind
of a rallying point for the Green
Lantern's what this meant was that the
guardians of the universe needed him or
at least what was left of the guardians
ganthet and sayd they needed him alive
and so getting with kyle rayner having
him reach into the afterlife and bring
Hal Jordan back while Hal Jordan was
there among the dead he had spoke with
his predecessor a bansuri the guy who
had given Hal Jordan his very first ring
an avid swore statement was pretty
cryptic to say the least but he had
simply just said go find hope now the
initial indication here was that it
meant go find the blue lanterns and so
what ends up happening is how a Hal
Jordan alongside Kyle Rayner basically
raced off to a place called the misery
mound now the misery mound is basically
just kind of a mountain you know
occupied by all these creatures and so
on that exists for the purpose of just
stripping people of their desire for
hope and that's the necessity that's the
nature of the misery mound when it comes
to the blue lanterns of course I imagine
a lot of this might be new to people who
are stumbling across this but when it
comes to the blue lanterns they are a
lantern court Fred
kated on hope and they're probably the
most powerful just because hope is the
only thing that people can have that
will allow them to do anything else with
people like Atrocitus for example
Atrocitus as the head of the Red Lantern
Corps feels nothing but rage but his
rage is predicated on the hope that he
can succeed in destroying all the other
Lantern cores in existence so again
everything boils down to hope and that's
the reason why it is the blue lanterns
are so powerful but when the Lantern
cores were created by Geoff Johns back
when he was doing his massive run every
Lantern Corps had to have a caveat which
is to say they had to have a weakness
and so the idea is that with the blue
lanterns they function at their absolute
peak when they're accompanied by a Green
Lantern and that's why this is important
is because Saint Walker as the last
remaining blue lantern is powerful in
his own right but his power is bolstered
and complemented by the Green Lantern's
and so with the arrival of Hal Jordan
alongside Kyle Rayner
what this does is it basically begins
the process of beefing up the abilities
of the Blue Lantern Corps beefing up the
abilities of Saint Walker the problem
with this is that when it comes to blue
lanterns and the reason why this misery
mound is really happening is because
blue lanterns have to constantly feel
hope that brings us into the idea of the
blue lanterns basically falling of being
eradicated there was a story that was
written and I cannot remember what it
was called for the life of me but it
dealt with a villain named relic and
relic was a guy who had come from a
previous universe where the emotional
spectrum of basically run rampant and
then eventually just kind of went away
and the result was that all life in the
universe if I remember correctly had
basically gone the result of this is
that he had shown up in the main DC
Universe for the purpose of
exterminating all the Lantern course
keeping the Fowler from running awry and
then forcing the same result of his
universe the first Lantern Corps that he
targeted were the blue lanterns now the
blue lanterns were the easiest to target
because despite how powerful they were
if at any point a Blue Lantern does not
feel hope their ring will take off the
ring will leave them hanging and they'll
just be as powerless as anybody else
woe betide them if their ring leaves
them while they're in the depths of
space and they can't breathe so because
of that during this whole skirmish with
the blue lanterns were basically just
falling left and right st. Walker was
the last guy left ultimately saved
Walker lost connection with his blue
Lantern ring and the blue lanterns were
no more now eventually he regained it
and what that did is it went into DC
rebirth the problem was that when DC
rebirth first kicked off we didn't know
what Saint Walker was
we had no idea where he was or what was
going on there was no information on his
character what this reveals is that he's
basically been off fighting the misery
mound and the misery mound serves a
purpose of trying to relinquish people
of their hope of trying to exterminate
all hope in their entirety now again
because this is pretty new in relation
to DC rebirth which is to say we're
about a year and a half two years out
from DC rebirth in terms of the lead-up
the main event itself all that kind of
good stuff
a lot of folks are still jumping into
caldron in the Green Lantern Corps for
the very first time and so because of
this we're basically picking up into the
idea of people learning about all this
for the first time and that's why this
misery man is here to basically give
people who are reading for the first
time an understanding of what the blue
lanterns are about now the idea here is
that with Hal Jordan and with Kyle
Rayner basically being subdued by the
mystery mound it shows us what it does
and again the misery mound exists for
the purpose of just taking people's hope
away but it's not like an energy thing
right like it's not like it attaches
these tendrils a system how I'm
stripping you of your hope instead it's
very much similar to like the black
mercy plants for example you attach the
black mercy plant to a person and they
just see their perfect dreams forever
and ever and ever and they're basically
just held prisoner until they die with
regards to this a person is basically
forced to see the one thing that they
love the most the one thing they would
love to see happen and then that
beautiful future is transformed into a
nightmare in the case of Hal Jordan he
has a family he has children he has
Carol Ferris set aside and then suddenly
that shifts into a nightmare where he
goes back to being a villain and just
everybody around him dies when it comes
to Kyle Rayner he's basically the white
lantern he's effectively DC's space
Jesus because of that he sees himself as
a savior of all life as a representation
of all life being a protector in the
most definitive statement the problem
with this is his nightmare is falling
down and becoming paralyzed becoming a
villain now remember what these
characters they've experienced this kind
of thing before Kyle Rayner did become
parallax the living embodiment of fear
during Sinestro Corps war Hal Jordan has
lost almost everything he cared about in
some form or fashion friends family
loved ones a whole nine yards and so the
idea is that with them basically
experiencing this horrible nightmare
Saint Walker as a Blue Lantern begins to
empower them with hope and in doing so
allows them to basically break free of
the misery mounds so again this misery
man is pretty powerful but is really the
emotional connection that exists between
these three lanterns that makes them
able to beat the misery mound in the
first place now following this it goes
into a whole explanation of hate the
guardians of the universe at me out here
in order to basically make sure that I
could find hope that kind of a thing
because remember ganthet and sayd as the
guardians of the universe were the ones
who made the blue lantern rings in the
first place now their goal in terms of
why it is that Hal Jordan came and why
it is a kyle rayner came again hits back
to the nature of the blue lantern rings
blue lantern rings can only function at
the peak if they're accompanied by a
Green Lantern ring and so having Hal
Jordan there was one because of the fact
that he's the one that got the message
from heaven sewer but too because if st.
Walker is in danger his Lantern ring
will bolster the power of st. Walker's
ring now Kyle Rayner being there is
because as the guy who's basically the
nature of life itself he can resurrect
the dead the goal of the guardians of
the universe the goal of ganthet and
sayd
is to basically use a kyle rayner as the
white lantern to reach in and grab the
life essences of those blue lanterns who
perished from Saint Walker and resurrect
them from the dead using Saint Walker is
kind of an anchor to do so to go into
the afterlife to grab those guys say hey
you have to come back and so that's the
whole nature of this that's the whole
purpose of this entire story in terms of
those characters now what isn't
happening here is that once this really
begins to go into effect we get a
massive glimpse of what it is that dr.
Manhattan can do now it's not explicitly
stated but we're effectively told that's
the case when it comes to Kyle Rayner
and when it comes to him speaking with
the Guardians once they began the
process of basically using Kyle to try
to reach into the afterlife and grab
these blue lanterns it should have been
seamless go into st. Walker's mind grab
the connections to the blue lanterns
speak with them whatever is it he had do
and then bring them back the problem
with this is that someone gets in his
way someone stops Kyle Rayner from being
able to do this we know that just
because of the fact that the entire
event come crashing down now again the
biggest indication were given here is
that we run into st. Walker's simply
saying I felt a presence an intruder
that was barring our paths now when it
comes to the white lantern in DC Comics
there are characters that can overpower
him I mean like the presence for example
probably the spectre you know there's a
few characters out there that could
overpower the white lantern because
they're just that
powerful we have no reason to believe
that the presents the spectre The
Phantom Stranger held even imperiex in
the 1990s we have no reason to believe
that any of those characters have a
reason to bar that half of white lantern
kyle rayner
resurrecting the blue lanterns
resurrecting hope the idea here is that
dr. Manhattan is the one that's keeping
that from happening and it all fits into
the very notion of the blue lanterns
themselves the blue lanterns embody hope
the blue lanterns are insanely powerful
the other half of this is that this sees
the destruction of the white Lantern
ring Kyle Rayner is no longer the white
Lantern and there are no white lanterns
anymore that's the important thing about
this that's the biggest takeaway from
this and the reason why is because let's
say for example that Justice League
versus Watchmen unfolds and we've got
document Hatton fighting the Justice
League there's been time so really I
think it was during blackest night or
brightest day there was a point where
the entire Justice League became white
lanterns they were all as powerful as
Kyle Rayner the biggest issue this
represents is that if dr. Manhattan
shows up and dr. Manhattan had to fight
all these white lanterns it would be
epic and it would be cool but most
people would look at that and say sure
he could probably defeat Kyle Rayner but
no way he could defeat like eight white
lanterns that's ridiculous and so why
even go down that route why not just
wipe out the white lanterns in their
entirety that way you don't have to
worry about this the other half is that
the white lantern story arc of Kyle
Rayner had basically reached his end
Halloween are becoming the white lantern
was kind of this pristine dough of his
whole story going all the way back to
the mid 1990s with Emerald Twilight Hal
Jordan becoming a bad guy destroying all
the Green Lantern's ganthet showing up -
Kyle Rayner and saying you are the last
of the lanterns here's a ring use it
wisely all that led to Kyle Rayner
becoming a white lantern to this moment
when he goes back to being who he was
before because with the white Lantern
ring being an amalgamation of all these
other Lantern rings one ends up
happening is they all basically
dispersed the white Lantern ring
shatters the other emotions form into
their own rings they dispersed across
the universe and they start looking for
new house the only exception to that is
the Green Lantern ring which rebonds
itself to Kyle Rayner setting him back
to who he was before before all of
this stuff you know with the white
lantern ring all kicked out and so the
idea seems to be that he's kind of going
back to the era of ayaan but at the very
least Carl Reiner's character is going
back to the beginning it's kind of
resetting everything back to zero to a
degree now it's not a reboot or anything
like that we'll probably see the white
lanterns return that's the indication
here dr. Manhattan is more powerful than
the white lanterns that's the
implication but I'm kind of curious what
you guys think you guys think that's
true do you think dr. Manhattan is more
powerful than a white lantern I'm just
kind of curious about that okay so
getting into DC rebirth one of the funny
things is I've been seeing comments
recently of people asking me to do more
DC videos we literally alternate every
other day it's like Marvel DC Marvel DC
like Monday Wednesday and Friday are the
Marvel Days Sunday Tuesday and Thursday
or the DC days and then Saturday is when
we do like Omega Beyond omega-level
mutant so I don't really know what those
guys are talking about but with regards
to Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps remember this story deals more
with like the Green Lantern Corps in
space and it's kind of interesting I
didn't even think about it until earlier
today but in DC Comics you've always had
like the Green Lantern Corps and then
the Green Lantern books or at least you
did for a while the Green Lantern Corps
dealt with the Green Lantern characters
outside of like Earth's Green Lantern's
basically and then you had the Green
Lantern stories which dealt with Earth's
Green Lantern so who is always kind of
interesting it was like the Superman
action comics you know line of stories
but the idea here is that this basically
gives us one set of events that
essentially leads into another and what
this does is it basically creates what I
like to call the Sinestro Corps Civil
War because that's basically what it is
now initially but this seems pretty
straightforward right in the Sun so
there's basically some guy who works at
a giant Bank it's like one of these big
cosmic banks that exists the biggest one
in the universe is where a lot of like
Universal companies and things like that
store their money the banks effectively
robbed really well at least the campaign
is being launched to rob this Bank and
the reason for that is because there's
basically just a guy who works there and
he's like whatever let's rob this place
I mean there's no reason why we can't
this of course leads into the Green
Lantern Corps now of course the Green
Lantern Corps at this moment in time
serves as a police force of source but
remember the Green Lantern's and the
Sinestro Corps are basically merged into
a singular group which is kind of
interesting because when the Sinestro
Corps first popped up they were the
mortal enemies of the Green Lantern's
the idea though was that the Sinestro
Corps was
led by FAL Sinestro and the result is
that once he was believed to have been
killed in the first story arc of DC
rebirth the leadership of the Sinestro
Corps fell to his daughter a former
Green Lantern who joined the yellow
lanterns now of course we're going back
on Sundays and going through and
explaining all that Green Lantern mythos
and so if you're curious as to why that
happens all that comes out on Sundays
were actually at blackest night at the
moment worse like the rise of the Black
Lantern cores and all the dead
superheroes are coming back to life but
the arrival of the Sinestro and Green
Lantern Corps is again they're really
just more of a peacekeeping force they
basically grab these guys they whisk
them away they're taken back to mojo the
planet of the Green Lantern Corps and
they're basically made to stand trial
and that's really about it
the issue with this is that we end up
finding out a member of the Green
Lantern Corps is basically getting sick
now this Green Lantern is a guy by the
name of tomar - and he's actually the
son of tomar a the reason why I bring
this up and the reason why I'm kind of
taking a second to talk about this is
because tomar to interim RA have a
pretty long-standing history in the
Green Lantern landscape really more
tomar ray than a son tomar - but the
idea is that tomar ray was one of the
original Green Lantern's that is to say
one of them individuals who fought
alongside Hal Jordan before he went
crazy was possessed by parallax and
killed all the Green Lantern's the
result is that when Omar too was given
the ring of his father there was some
animosity when Hal Jordan returned
during the events of the original Green
Lantern rebirth but as time progressed
tomar too began to develop a kind of
respect for Hal Jordan and then
eventually became a mutual thing where
tomar - came to the realization that how
Dourdan had basically turned over a new
leaf he's proved himself time and time
again in the Green Lantern stories to be
one of the most important and best
aspects of their team really this guy
who in a lot of ways embodies what it
means to be a Green Lantern the reason
why this is important actually becomes
clear because it's the focal point of
this story and the reason why everything
ends up happening and so what we do is
we pick up with the aftermath of the
last story that I believe we covered the
one called prism of time it was
basically the idea that Kyle Rayner son
had come from the future and then
basically was able to possess pure
willpower the result is that he used his
abilities to effectively destroy all the
members of the Green Lantern's we seem
to be enemies of them the result is that
it ended up with Kyle Rayner facing off
against his son and ultimately his son
was killed
is important because kyle rayner hid
this fact from sir on ik not - of course
sir on ik being the daughter of a
thousand estra now of course sir on egg
is basically trying to escape her
father's legacy
right like Thal sinestro was a Green
Lantern who abuses power he fell to the
dark side so to speak form the Sinestro
Corps and it was an enemy of the Green
Lantern's ever since she's been trying
to escape that now over the course of
Jeff John's run and again we'll get
through this kind of stuff she basically
found herself in a relationship with
Kyle Rayner the issue with this is that
when the son of Kyle Rayner arrived in
the present day how Rana realised it was
his son but he didn't realize it until
after his son was dead and so because of
this when he realized that it was
basically the child of himself and sir
onic he actually hid that information
from her the other half of this is he's
basically trying to convince her to join
the Green Lantern's under the idea that
he looks to the future and says okay
our son basically became a villain and
maybe it's because of the fact that
cirrhotic fell back to the Sinestro
Corps
maybe it's because of any number of
things you know any any situation that
can lead to their child becoming a bad
guy and so what he ended up looking to
do was basically move her towards the
aspect of being a Green Lantern without
her really knowing what his true
motivations were so again there's a
couple plots going on with that kind of
a thing now in terms of the Green
Lantern's realizing the fact that one of
their members had killed a member of the
Sinestro Corps this comes by way of one
of the Raiders but where the Green
Lantern's saying we're gonna lock you up
we're gonna fill you in jail you're
gonna stand trial for your crimes his
answer is no you're not you're gonna let
me go because I have video evidence to
prove that one of your Green Lantern's
killed a yellow lantern now in normal
circumstances it wouldn't matter but
remember with ceramic leading the
Sinestro Corps and Jon Stewart of Earth
leading the Green Lantern Corps they
have a truce and so because of this when
they're faced with this information
there's a little bit of a rift in the
Green Lanterns all the way up at the
very top which is to say how Jordan
largely considered to be the greatest of
the Green Lantern's the most decorated
and Jon Stewart who's currently running
the show the reason behind this is
because for Hal Jordan the question has
to be asked what's going on here is any
of this true but at the same time he
doesn't want to believe it Jon Stewart
is a pragmatic man if he's given a piece
of evidence that may have some validity
then his goal is to seek it out and see
whether or not it's absolutely true so
really he's a lot more logical here
whereas Hal Jordan is thinking more
emotion
than anything else now the other half of
this is that for John Stewart if this is
true if it's true that a member of the
Green Lantern Corps killed a member of
the Sinestro Corps and that is strictly
forbidden according to the truce they
have it will bring everything crashing
down because one of these green lanterns
went rogue which is also an indication
that he does not have as much control of
the green lanterns as he thought he did
and so again this all gets kind of wild
but ultimately we end up picking up with
cirrhotic traveling to the morgue to see
the son of Colerain of course again she
doesn't really know the fact that it is
her son but going through here and
performing all these different studies
because of the fact that she's a doctor
DNA analysis different things like that
she's basically told this being has two
sides to his DNA one side is human the
father being Karina the other side is
karubian I guess is how you pronounce it
uh the child a cirrhotic not two now of
course this sends her immediately over
the edge because what she's basically
being told here if she has fought
alongside in a conflict that resulted in
her own son being killed this is massive
not only that when Hal Jordan travels to
see tomar - he basically ends up
discovering at the same time that Jon
Stewart does that tomar - was the one
who killed this member of the Sinestro
Corps now of course Jon Stewart finds
out by virtue of the fact that Guy
Gardner another one of the Green
Lanterns and our kill Oh a member of the
Sinestro Corps both of whom were working
together had basically gone on this
mission to essentially grab this spot
there was basically observing the entire
thing and they had looked at the video
footage and came to the realization that
tomar two had come into this crime
before Hal Jordan he's coming across
circumstantial evidence and that's why
these things are totally different Jon
Stewart's got video proof Hal Jordan
just comes across
tomar - who's using his willpower to
keep this Sinestro ring confined now
this is also kind of an interesting
situation because it's not something DC
really talks about so much which is to
say what happens when a Green Lantern
goes to sleep but before we get to that
what we end up doing is we pick up with
with tomar - again encountering this
member of the Sinestro Corps and this
guy basically says look I will never
honor a truce between the Green
Lantern's and the Sinestro Corps that's
never going to happen and this guy was
basically a serial killer of children no
less and so there's really no mercy on
really any round with regards to this
guy but the issue is the Green Lantern's
are designed as a peacekeeping and a
police force they're not does
to be this strong on of some dictator
somewhere so they can't just take the
law into their own hands they're not
judge jury and executioner and so
because of this when tome r2 is
basically goaded and this guy
essentially says hey look yeah I'll go
to jail and I'll stand trial and I'll go
through their little science cells
essentially the the prison of the Green
Lanterns and I'll break out just like I
did before and I'll go back and all I'll
kill kids again ultimately tomar two
kills and now in truth this makes sense
it makes it makes perfect sense the
purpose of prison is the hope that they
can basically find Redemption but some
individuals are not looking for
redemption they don't believe that what
they do is wrong or if they do know it's
wrong they don't care they enjoy doing
it this member of the Sinestro Corps was
one of those and so in a moment of anger
and in a moment of Wrath tomar too
kills him in cases is ring and that
basically tells us partner you saw
nothing and you heard nothing we end up
finding out when tomar two is talking to
Hal Jordan the reason why he's been
getting sick is because of the fact that
in order to keep this yellow lantern
ring encased in this box of willpower he
can never sleep this is kind of cool
because again this is basically the idea
that when a Green Lantern goes to sleep
they presumably take off the Rings any
number of things and the result is that
they are effectively powerless in this
instance this guy has been using his
willpower
day and night 24 hours a day non-stop
never sleeping and has pushed his bye to
the point of physical exhaustion the
problem with this is that again in the
face of this circumstantial evidence how
Jordan doesn't want to believe it's true
and that makes sense because he's
basically being told one of your oldest
friends and one of the best members of
the Green Lantern Corps killed a member
of the Sinestro Corps in cold blood this
member of the Sinestro Corps said fine I
will go to your science cells that is a
damning piece of evidence because it's
basically this guy saying I'd give up
it's really the idea really the goal of
Jon Stewart to sweep it under the rug
and to keep it all very hush-hush
now this is huge with regards to Jon
Stewart because he's always been a man
who had disliked moral viewpoint right
where he says okay there's right there's
wrong sure there's circumstantial
evidence but in the end we have to abide
by the law and the truth what he's
basically doing here is he's trying to
play both sides he's trying to
essentially say okay look this member of
the Green Lantern Corps committed a
crime against the Sinestro Corps
normally we would basically have him
executed or we would basically kick him
out but if anybody finds out that he
killed a member of the Sinestro Corps
every
we built is being destroyed it's gonna
come crashing down and so it's his idea
to basically take this guy throw him in
a science cell he'll never be seen or
heard from again and Noah we'll find out
what it was that he did make it go away
now of course transitioning back over to
the whole scenario with with surrounded
not to you and with Kyle Rayner she's
basically just pissed
she is mad as hell because in her mind
Kyle Rayner denied her something that
she should have had the right to know
Kyle Rayner basically knew that this guy
who died was their kid she was part of
this whole situation and never once what
she told this is a huge betrayal of
trust on the highest levels Kyle Rayner
had basically said come back to the
Green Lantern's I want you here I need
you in my life all the while hiding
something of such a high degree now if
he had gone to her almost immediately
after he found out and said okay hey
look here's everything that I know
maybe cirrhotic would be understanding
maybe she wouldn't the issue is that
Kyle did not afford her that opportunity
she had to find out the hard way she had
to be blindsided by this fact and so in
her anger and in her wrath she
completely falls back down to the role
of her father Sinestro now this is crazy
and it's actually pretty interesting
that this happens because cirrhotic
again had spent so much time trying to
assure people she was not like her
father she spent so much time trying to
fight that aspect of herself and prove
to herself above all others that she was
not Thal Sinestro all it took was the
betrayal from a close friend to make
that happen and that's really the center
point of all this Killing Joke example
all that ever takes is one bad day for
Thal Sinestro it was trying to impose
order on a planet fallen prey to
government corruption to corporate
corruption to people who just stuck
their head in the sand hoping the
world's problems would go away it was
him trying to restore order to all that
and being banished from the Green
Lantern Corps for abusing his power for
cirrhotic is her experiencing the trust
of someone that she loved of someone
that she trusted more than almost any
other and so it's a very very big deal
because as soon as this happens and of
course when it comes to you know Jon
Stewart making his discussion not
revealing the fact that a member of the
Green Lantern Corps killed a member of
the Sinestro Corps ultimately word gets
around and when it does all hell breaks
loose the Sinestro Corps come bolting
for this guy and they immediately like
they they're out for blood
they want this guy gone they want him
dead of course this leads directly to
how Jordan to John Stuart basically
drawing lines in the sand and saying
okay here's the here's where things
stand
you know Guy Gardner shows up with the
body of coroner says somebody imprinted
a Sinestro Corps symbol on his chest not
knowing that it's cirrhotic and it's
then basically saying hey look everybody
needs to calm down everybody needs to
relax only for Sarada to show up and say
I'm the one who branded kyle rayner in
her anger here she's speaking out of out
of fear she's speaking out of the fact
that she's emotionally crushed that's
really what this says and in her mind
experiencing such a huge betrayal for
kyle rayner extends out into everything
else being heartbroken and saying well
this alliance was never gonna work this
alliance was never gonna happen it's
somebody just getting frustrated and
just tearing the house apart out of
anger he's essentially saying we were
all duped we were all tricked we were
told that things would be great we were
told that things would be amazing we
were brought here at a Mogo they allowed
us to build a central power battery the
source of our power they allowed us to
build it here so that we could all be
even but the truth is that we never work
and we know that because a member of the
Sinestro Corps kills a member of the
Green Lantern Corps well man justice
needs to be served something needs to be
done but a member of the Green Lantern
Corps kills a member of the Sinestro
Corps well I mean you know let's not be
too hasty in our rush to judgment you
know so because of that what she's
seeing is a contradiction on behalf of
the Green Lantern's now heavy is the
crown that's the price Jon Stewart is
bank because he's literally trying to
hold all this together and none of it's
working if so what he basically does is
he says look here's how things are gonna
be those of you guys who are faithful
those of you guys who want to remain on
the side of good who believe that good
can come out of this alliance stand on
this side a lot people who don't agree
go join sir on it half the Sinestro
Corps goes to her side half the Sinestro
Corps stays on the Green Lantern side
and it just Oh roughs into this massive
battle it's essentially just Green
Lantern versus Sinestro Corps member
versus Sinestro Corps member it's
literally a Sinestro Corps Civil War the
problem is that it does not last very
long and the reason why is because what
ended up happening is that in the middle
of all this Jon Stewart effectively put
this sort of caveat in the central power
battery of the Sinestro Corps in the
sense that if he basically execute this
command codename khatma what it
essentially does is it shuts down the
Sinestro Corps block or
it overrides them and keeps them from
attacking Green Lantern's this does not
help his case what this does if anything
is it actually instills a more
entrenched belief among the members of
the Sinestro Corps that Jon Stewart the
Green Lantern's never trusted him but
for Jon Stewart he's also got a
legitimate argument here again when the
Sinestro Corps war first picked up first
picked off the Sinestro Corps took no
prisoners they came across a Green
Lantern that Green Lantern was dead
every single time there were no
prisoners taken no quarter given
and so from Jon Stewart's perspective is
a legitimate gripe to take but one is up
happening is cirrhotic grabs the
faithful Sinestro Corps members takes
off into space and says look we'll find
our own way we will form a new base of
operations we will find a place that we
can call our own and we'll call it a day
that'll basically be it now the reason
why this is also a really big moment too
is because we're Jon Stewart and
everybody's like okay look everything's
kind of quelled we have the faithful
here on our side we don't know when
they'll come back but it'll be somewhere
else later on down the line for right
now the conflict is done what we end up
doing is picking up on the planet chord
in the antimatter universe and what we
end up finding out is that FAL Sinestro
is not dead he's very much alive he's
actually just been resurrected and so
all we have to do is just wait until his
body physically returns back to his
normal state then when it does the
question becomes what happens to the
Sinestro Corps after that so while this
technically takes place before the
events of dark nights metal in terms of
chronology I consider it to be a tie-in
and the reason why is because this deals
with the whole idea of in metal in terms
of what is capable what it can do and
why it's so powerful in the realm of DC
Comics remember when it came to Dark
Knights metal that basically amplified a
really sort of expanded on the nature of
a metal prior to Dark Knights metal and
metal was just this this material that
existed out there but there wasn't
really anything special about it had
magical properties and that was really
about it what Dark Knight's metal does
is it basically says that if metal is
permeated throughout the entirety of the
DC Multiverse but it all originates from
the dark multiverse and so it's cool
because what this also does is it sees
the return of one of the most powerful
villains that existed out there in the
realm of DC Comics now initially we
basically just pick up with these beings
that look very similar to Celestials
from Marvel Comics in terms of the
physical form in the middle of all this
while the Green Lantern's are sort of
rest
with a fallout of the whole fractured
story arc which basically saw the
alliance between the Green Lantern's and
the Sinestro Corps coming to an end some
members of the Sinestro Corps staying
with the Green Lantern's but a good
portion of them basically leaving and
taking off into space what this means is
the Green Lantern's numbers are
basically down to almost zero again keep
in mind that when most of the Green
Lantern's were kind of shunted off to
the beginning of all things to the
beginning of time more or less in the
universe what it did is it allowed the
Sinestro Corps to sort of rise to
prominence as a police force but where
Thal Sinestro himself was eventually
defeated and believed to have been
killed the result is that his daughter
cirrhotic took over the Sinestro Corps
as a former Green Lantern now where her
father was very villainous in terms of
how he ran the whole Sinestro Corps she
ran it is more of a superhero kind of
team and forming an alliance with the
Green Lantern's when that ended it was
all predicated on the idea that the
child of Kyle Rayner the Green Lantern
and cirrhotic not two came from the
future Bette rod was killed and then
Kyle Rayner didn't tell sonic what
happened and the result is that she lost
all trust in the Green Lantern and sort
of became a villain to Sydney Oh
declared herself the new Sinestro and
took off into space you know we covered
that with the whole lot the whole
fractured storyline but the long and
short of this is that the Green
Lantern's numbers are still very very
thin and so it was really left to Jon
Stewart as a leader of the Green Lantern
Corps to try to hold it all together
it's always really doing double duty in
a lot of different ways on one side he's
going through and he's trying to make
sure that what's left of the Green
Lantern's still maintain themselves as a
cohesive team which by and large they're
doing for the most part the other half
of this is that the universe still needs
to be protected there's still villains
out there there's still things as the
Green Lantern's have to do and they're
trying to maintain that role but in the
midst of this huge you know spark of
energy that's more or less picked up by
Jon Stewart of course he sends Kyle
Rayner and he sends a Hal Jordan to
investigate the problem is when they get
there what they end up finding is an
entire star system has been totally
obliterated when this happens of course
what we end up having our boom tubes
that are opening what immediately
follows is not just the character of
Orion but Omega beams and Omega beams
are usually a direct indication of the
presence of Darkseid now one of the
things that I want to talk about here is
the character of Orion because we've
talked about him before before a lot of
people who are jumping into DC rebirth
Orion is a foreign concept to them they
don't really know anything about him so
when it comes to the new god you've
basically got apocalypse with Darkseid
and you've got new Genesis with
highfather in the new 52 there
we brothers but the whole idea here is
that they represent the very nature of
the opposing dichotomies of good and
evil that's really what they are
apocalypses evil New Genesis is good now
in a lot of ways their motivations can
be called into question there are times
where you know the good guys New Genesis
guys have done some pretty questionable
things but overall despite what they
might do in the short term in the long
term they're good guys they're heroes
and they function that way now with the
whole idea of these two opposing forces
inevitably they went to war with one
another and they Ward for like eons and
eons and eons in order to basically
construct a truce what ended up
happening is one of the beings that was
part of the whole new gods mythos called
met Ron had basically brokered a truce
between the two worlds what they would
do is they would exchange their sons and
so what ended up happening is a Ryan the
son of Darkseid was sent to live with
highfather whereas the son of highfather
scot-free was sent to live with Darkseid
that's the reason why scot-free mr.
miracle is kind of like a master escape
artist because the locks were so strong
and so durable on apocalypse that him
being able to basically break out of
those made him capable of breaking
through some of the the best you know
devices that exists out there in terms
of locks and codes and different things
like that but Orion being a member of
the New Gods has always been more or
less the Prince of New Genesis which is
to say he adopted son more or less of hi
father and the ruling plays has always
been the sort of on-again off-again hero
that's worked alongside the various
superheroes now the reason why I say
on-again off-again is just because of
the fact that remember for years and
years and years the new gods are
basically isolated to their own line of
comics so you didn't see them crossover
all the time but it was usually always a
Ryan who is like the liaison when it
came to the new gods working alongside
superheroes but there's history here is
really kind of the overall point that
robert van biddies making here it's not
like the new gods are meeting the Green
Lantern's for the very first time not
only that the last time these two groups
met Kyle Rayner was the white Lantern he
was the most powerful of all the
lanterns who were out there the funny
thing about this though is that when a
Ryan shows up he's like look you know
there's something hunting us in New
Genesis trying to kill off all the New
Gods we need your all's help and we
really really need the White Lantern
like if you guys know if the White
Lantern is here get him because like we
could really use his help we really need
the white Lantern and it's funny because
Kyle Rayner used to be the white lantern
and he's not anymore so it's kind of
interesting and of course this basically
falls in the shoulders of just the Green
Lantern's to cope with
their own but keep in mind when it comes
to the New Gods they are in a lot of
ways almost immutable and indestructible
I mean they can be killed but it takes
beings of immense power in order to pull
it off and so when the New Gods show up
and they're like we need we you know we
basically need help amia Stein's are
that dire because under normal
circumstances Green Lantern's should not
be able to take on and defeat beings
that are capable of overpowering New
Gods the problem is that things are just
that bad now of course with these Omega
beams basically hitting Orion these
Omega beams function in the exact same
capacity that we're used to once their
sicked on the target they find that
target and they keep chasing after them
until they hit them or until that target
goes to a place but the Omega beams
can't follow on the surface this looks
like dark side it looks like dark side
is somehow a reappeared dark sides back
and waging a war against the New Gods
the problem with this is that once they
basically get you know a Ryan onto a
stretcher when they get him back what is
up happening is his heart is more or
less shut down when his heart is
restarted when he's brought back he
immediately panics because he's like all
hope is lost here this planet is gonna
be obliterated because the Omega beams
are gonna continue following him until
they're dead and again the reason for
this is because Orion is basically being
chased by a giant machine of sorts
basically one of these Celestials and
the cynthia's Omega beams after him and
that once it believed that he was dead
when his heart stopped it backed off but
when he was brought back and immediately
started chasing after him again so this
thing appears to have been designed for
the purpose of just tracking down and
killing new gods everywhere it can find
them but notice this this thing is
wildly powerful I mean it's huge it's
monstrous in size it's very much like a
celestial from Marvel Comics and it's
really intriguing where the Green
Lantern's face-off against it as best
they can evacuating people out where
they can't what we end up having is the
head of the medical staff that was able
to save save Orion has effectively
created a fake heart of sorts it's
really this idea that this heart can be
used to basically continue circulating
blood throughout the body of Orion while
his physical heart is stopped and so
what ends up happening here is once they
pull this off once Kyle Rayner creates
this construct and is basically able to
use it to artificially continue pumping
blood throughout the body of Orion
because as physically well his physical
heart is believed to have stopped this
thing immediately backs off and it moves
on to its next target so again
constantly going after all these
different new gods tracking these guys
down taking these guys out this is a
pretty overwhelming force now following
this
once we get him back to the Green
Lantern base of operations that's when
the information begins to come in
remember when it comes to Robert Van
Diddy's you know writing style he's from
what I've been able to see a lot of this
kind of an introductory thing you know
things going crazy things going nuts and
then we start to get into the
explanation it's designed to grab us and
realists in these massive machines are
basically being referred to as golems
but the reason why I consider this to be
a Dark Knight's metal tie-in is because
what it does is it picks up on two
things the first is the nature of in
metal in terms of the fact that it's one
of the most powerful concepts that
exists out there but the second is also
the character of yuga Khan now use akan
as meant most people probably don't know
is the father of Darkseid but the way
his history is done here is a little bit
intriguing when it came to the new 52
and the origin of Darkseid himself Yuga
Khan didn't really exist he wasn't
really there Darkseid is us you know
basically led a rebellion against the
old gods took them all out and then him
and highfather went to war against each
other and that was the end of that Yuga
Caan is largely a pre new 52 character
meaning a character who largely had a
bulk of his appearances before 2011 now
even before then he goes all the way
back to the 1970s well you're talking
about a guy who's appeared in DC Comics
less than like a hundred and fifty times
he hasn't shown up all that often but
the mekin nations and the schemes of
yuga khan are for the most part always
the same he was the original God among
all gods the most powerful of all gods
in existence here an apocalypse with an
iron fist he was hardcore he was
ruthless and he was cutthroat but he
desired to attain absolute power and
tried to enter the source basically the
source of all energy of all beings that
exists in the DC Universe the result is
that once he tried to pass through the
source wall like all other beings who
have tried to enter the source he was
locked inside the wall and he was
presumably stuck there for all eternity
what this does is it expands on that
initial origin and it basically says
that what you kakan also had was
basically an army of sorts that was
composed almost entirely of in fettle
and the reason why this matters is
because no one believed this army was
real a lot of that was because when it
came to Yuga Khan because him being
locked in the source wall had happened
so long before the events of a lot of
the modern-day stories had taken place
the result is that he was largely
believed to have just been a myth but
with the idea that Yuga Khan had
basically been locked away in a source
wall and was essentially trying to
engineer his own escape these machines
effectively react
this army came to fruition again with
two main purposes the first was to
follow the campaign follow the
programming instituted by Yuka Khan to
eliminate all individuals who could
possibly take over as the ruler of
Apocalypse and his absence effectively
eliminating Aires
the second of this was to bring yuga
Khan back now remember right now when it
comes to DC rebirth darkside is not
darkside anymore he's not there anymore
he's basically just a baby
he doesn't really pose a challenge in
terms of people who are capable of being
able to take over the throne of
Apocalypse in the absence of yoga Khan
then it means Oh Ryan is the most
logical person to do it because I Ryan
is the biological son of Darkseid so a
lot of history that's thrown in a lot of
the backlog of stories that have taken
place but following this what they end
up doing is they basically say okay we
have to search his mind even further
because we have to find out where hi
father is hi father being a leader of
all the new gods in New Genesis is
largely believed to be one of the more
powerful of the new gods right up there
with the power of Darkseid and so if the
Green Lantern's are struggling against
these golems then of course highfather
is perceived to be their best measure of
being able to take these guys out
simultaneously if they are hunting new
gods then it stands to reason they're
hunting high father and so because of
this once they track down where it is
that high father may be at the only
thing they're able to gain is the name
of a person called light ray now light
ray is like the New Gods version of the
flash and his character is actually
pretty intriguing he made his first
appearance a new God to number one back
in 1971 but like a lot of the other new
gods he was given a pretty cool origin
in the sense that him and Orion were
extremely close friend the issue here is
that somewhere along the line light ray
and Orion who basically discovered like
an apocalyptic outpost or something like
that there was on new Genesis and the
result was that following a battle my
way was hit with like a whole bunch of
solar radiation he fell into a coma for
a while and when he popped back up he
had all these solar powers he could
basically manipulate light itself in a
multitude of different ways now one of
the things that he did is he actually
ended up pushing himself and kind of
becoming the fastest of all the new gods
so but a lot of ways light Ray was like
Marvel's Macari that was an eternal who
basically devoted all of his power to
pushing his speed to the absolute limits
with light ray it's much the same way
but because of this was white ray being
the fastest of all the new gods he's
basically able to traverse all through
space and time using you know his power
of flight but with Hal Jordan basically
tasked with trying to track down
Raye and ultimately locate whether or
not he actually has high father with him
the biggest hindrance he has is as
constructs do not seem to be able to
move as fast as light rays able to
travel now of course this is actually a
pretty amazing moment here because while
he's trying to pilot the ship he
basically ends up backing the whole
thing down he really just kind of slows
down and it seems like all hope is lost
when he's basically met with an image of
his father now we're not told how he got
here it's basically this whole idea that
his dad appears and offers these words
of encouragement to Hal Jordan I have
faith in you I believe in you but it's a
very touching moment because one of the
things that's really always emphasized
when it comes to the character of how as
his father always played an exceedingly
large role in his life albeit the fact
that his father had died when he was
younger the results of this is that
every time how Jordan flies whenever it
is and he goes on some mission or
something like that he needs to kind of
pep himself up prepare for what it is
it's gonna happen his question is what
would my dad do what would my father do
in this situation and again it's a
really beautiful and touching aspect of
his character because of course where
the questions asked am i hallucinating
you you know what in the world is going
on here instead of his father sort of
being just this kind of general image he
speaks and moves as if you were actually
there in real life and even goes as far
as to say I don't really know if you're
hallucinating me or not you're basically
in the wake of a cosmic God that's
flying at the speed of light it's very
ambiguous it's very cloak-and-dagger but
it's not designed to answer the question
is his father really here this designed
to emphasize the nature and the
relationship between Hal Jordan and his
dad and how big of a role his father
plays and so again because of the fact
that his dad was courageous because of
the fact that his dad did whatever it
took in order to achieve the goal Hal
Jordan follows the exact same path and
where he begins flying his ship pulling
up on the speed of light what we also
end up having is this warning coming
from his construct that Hal Jordan is
approaching a speed force singularity
what this means is that if he kept
traveling faster he would have entered
the speed force mode most likely Hal
Jordan may have gained the powers of the
flash it's cool with him basically
running into highfather running into
light ray he basically says look I can
take over from here if you guys need me
to I can help out and it makes sense
because hi father's response is despite
the powers of light ray while he is a
new God his energy is not infinite
eventually he'll tire out and with those
Omega beams chasing them down as he
begins to slow the beams do not slow
down with Hal Jordan grabbing hi father
bring him on board and basically taking
off between the two of them is
interesting because these Omega beams
are still following them and if that
caldron actually comes up with this
pretty ingenious plan where the
constructive calibrator is being used
continually to basically maintain the
construct disturbing is the heart of
Orion he's not really able to leave and
not really able to go anywhere instead
what we end up finding out is that
because of the fact that these are mega
beams are chasing after the new gods or
at least you know only those who are
present in this immediate vicinity
chasing after highfather
and because of the fact a Ryan is
believed to have been dead these golems
move on to their second process which is
trying to free a eunuch on from the
source wall now keep in mind if you
kakan is freed if this happens then all
hope is lost basically everybody's gonna
die the other question has to be asked
here is how does this coincide with the
Darkseid war Shazam one-shot those of
you guys who don't know Billy Batson
also known as Shazam really Captain
Marvel back in the 1930s derived his
powers from a handful of different gods
you know all of whom basically spelled
out the acronym Shazam the issue is that
during the original Darkseid war
storyline at the tail end of the new 52
Shazam got his powers from a new set of
gods one of which was yuga Khan the last
we saw him he was just kind of preparing
to institute his campaign so we don't
really know how to bridge this gap
between the last time we saw you the con
and how he ended up in the source wall I
don't really believe is a continuity err
just because DC rebirth plays continuity
pretty close to the best it may be that
kind of thing gets fleshed out later on
down the line most likely when it comes
to the return of Shazam himself whether
it's in a solo series or what have you
or if you'da khan manages to be freed
from the source wall and then gives us
this whole great big huge exposition on
what it wasn't happened with his
character and how he got to where he is
you know in DC gives us a whole
backstory but it's cool because remember
if you've akan gets out everybody dies
and so that's the first instance of the
of the Green Lantern's is to fight this
war on two fronts the first part is to
stop all these different guns and the
second is to keep them away from yuga
khan so it's a pretty desperate scenario
now of course with regards to hal jordan
and highfather essentially racing back
with the Omega beams following them they
basically play chicken and it's a pretty
genius maneuver here in the sense that
Hal Jordan effectively dies out of the
way just before the moment of impact and
the Omega beams hit one of the golems
and completely incinerate them funneling
that is a matter of trying to take out
as many other of these beans as they
can't
once they learn the weakness is
basically the the point in their chest
then it becomes a matter of just
creating as many constructs as they can
as large as they can and just hammering
it away at all until they can finally
take these guys out with all these
different golems having been defeated
the final one appears and so of course
highfather kind of jumps into the fray
and highfather is able to crack the
armor just enough for a John Stewart to
fire off a killing shot and to destroy
this thing but keep in mind hi father
while he is powerful is not all-powerful
he can be destroyed but the fact that
these things were designed for the
purpose of destroying new gods meant
that they had to have been designed for
the purpose of destroying new gods of
all power like highfather otherwise
there'd be no purpose in creating that
army and so as a result with the final
golem having been destroyed basically
haven't been taken out that impetus
basically falls on high father to sort
of you know taunt you become little bit
say hey there's no chance of you getting
out and really sort of calling it a day
and so the story basically wraps up this
quick little involvement with the new
gods and the Green Lantern's themselves
sort of teaming up these kind of wrap up
with a Ryan having his heart put back
into his chest
everybody's saying peace you know thanks
for helping out and they go their own
separate ways things wrap up pretty fast
it's not really one of these stories
that was designed to set the stage for
everything else that goes on and all
these expansive things and all that kind
of good stuff again it's just one of
these stories it's designed to remind us
characters like yuga khan still exist
there are some pretty formidable threats
out there the source wall all those
things are still out there so it is
pretty cool and it certainly is
interesting in terms of what may come
after this okay so continuing our
discussions on DC rebirth we pick up now
with Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern
Corps in fact what we're gonna do when
we get around to the end of this video
is we're gonna kind of wound out this
discussion on DC rebirth just because of
the fact that the end of this story will
actually see and even the story itself
will see kind of a return to familiarity
with regards to characters that we
haven't seen for quite some time and
again sort of set the stage for what DC
rebirth really is not really set the
stage but kind of explain what DC
rebirth you know is is really all about
but initially we pick up here with the
Templar Guardians now the Templar
guardians are kind of interesting
because as far as I'm aware they just
vanished
one day like they vanished really when
it came to the character of relic in
order to keep from spoiling things too
much because we'll talk about the
Templar guardians as we go through our
Green Lantern videos on Sunday the
Templar Guardians are basically a subset
of the guardians of the universe that
are guarding an exceedingly powerful
being like a being that's literally
going to lay way
to the entirety of all the Lantern
course it's good it's gonna be a blood
to happen but it's one of the best
stories ever but the other half of this
is that the Templar Guardians as far as
I'm aware basically like vanish during
the whole thing with relic and what I
mean by that is eventually the Templar
Guardians basically stepped away from
their role or really there was no need
for them to maintain their role anymore
and they kind of took up the position of
the other guardians of the universe and
the result is that instead of being
removed from the universal landscape
which is to say kind of keeping
themselves hidden off and really being
obsessed with the fact that they were
right all the time the Templar guardians
wanted to have more of a hand in things
now this led in to the introduction of
relic basically a character who was from
a previous universe I think it was and
it was the idea that his universe had
basically been overrun and destroyed by
people who were harvesting and using the
emotional spectrum and he wanted to keep
that from happening in the DC universe
as it existed now and so whose goal was
to basically destroy all the lanterns
but the fact remains here it is pretty
cool because the Templar guardians after
that again as far as I'm aware they were
just gone all we got was just ganthet
and sayd in DC comics and that's it it
is interesting and it's kind of
intriguing because it does really see
them come back here so it may very well
be that this you know this back end gets
explained assuming that you know I'm not
missing something but at this point we
actually transition over to a newly
introduced Green Lantern which is
actually a kid and it's cool because
when it comes to the Green Lantern's
more often than not when we see Green
Lantern's we see them usually as like
young adults or adults and so they've
kind of reached that point in their life
where they were like okay so like this
time to get down to business before a
kid they respond exactly the way that we
would like if we were given a Green
Lantern regular we're just gonna fly
around and have like the most fun ever
and that's exactly what happens you know
this kid experience you know experience
is all the joy and that's the benefit of
this is that it's kind of a fresh and
flux of innocence into a Green Lantern
quark that's been through so much
because remember the Green Lantern's
during the whole you know lost army and
edge of oblivion story they were
basically pushed almost to the brink of
extinction I mean their numbers dwindled
down to what amounts to a handful
relative to how big their numbers used
to be before when they were in the
thousands now they're down to you know a
few dozen maybe a hundred and so the
result is that they're they're really
doing the best they can to kind of keep
everything intact what the nudity does
here is he very much writes this and
away words like children of men for
example you know humanity's on the brink
of destruction and you know and no one's
having kids anymore and then suddenly a
woman gives birth to a kid and it's like
that
Kollek scene from that movie when you
know the rebels are fighting against the
British soldiers and then you know this
baby starts crying and the whole
conflict stops everyone stops until this
baby leaves and then the conflict kicks
back in again that's really what this is
designed to be it's innocence it's you
know John Stuart is the leader of the
Green Lantern's I almost forgot what
it's like to see a child enjoy life in
such a capacity because remember they're
out in space so they're largely removed
from all that stuff it is cool here
because this is one of those things
where Gant they kind of hinted the idea
of hey say do you ever thought about
having a kid but of course her her
response is well I mean I assume you're
talking about like lowering the
restriction I assume you're not talking
about having a child because we're kind
of old and I don't know if I could
survive it
but the fact remains here the cool thing
about vending is writing is that it's
very reminiscent of classic Green
Lantern stories in the sense that the
whole thing would kick up and then
here's what the Green Lantern's are
doing while it's going on now a lot of
that's because of the fact that when
Geoff Johns took up the Green Lantern
line of comics it was just one series of
events after another it's just event
after event after event after event
Sinestro Corps war blackest night
brightest take all these things just one
event after another and so there really
wasn't a whole lot of time to kind of
show the downtime of lanterns I mean
there was to a degree but it wasn't a
huge focal point he was building up the
mythos and expanding all these cores and
all that kind of cool stuff and so it's
almost like vendee Dee's run at least
right now in DC rebirth is more like us
catching our breath kind of sitting down
and saying okay now let's see what the
Green Lantern's are about and it's cool
because we get this moment you know
between Hal Jordan and Kyle later you
know where they're talking about you
know they're putting things back
together and they're helping us
civilization survive you know the
eruption of the volcano and different
things like that
problem with this is that in the middle
of ganthet and sayd you know talking to
this new green lantern and you know
basically informing them over the role
they play and the importance of the
power they possess they're suddenly met
by the arrival of enemies that we don't
see it so of course gaya that tells us
your girl run you know go get Kilowog go
tell somebody make people aware of
what's going on and then of course
ganthet and sayd are basically you know
kidnapped and taken away now from here
this little kid races off to the Green
Lanterns and there's like hey guys
till I get them to say they've been
kidnapped and these are going crazy and
we need your help and it's kind of funny
and so the result is that what we end up
finding out here is that they've been
taken by the controllers now the
controllers as they exist in DC Comics
really exists in a couple different
forms as you would expect with
characters who have been around long
enough
there's the pre-crisis version then
there's the post-crisis version
the pre-crisis version appeared back in
like 1967 I think it was and they were
basically characters who were just from
like a different universe and that was
really yeah I mean it was just one of
these old Jim shooter style stories from
way back in the day where it was like
well I mean you know they came from a
different universe and you know
something like that and they were trying
to keep this universe from being
destroyed or something on those lines
the controllers as we know them really
it's their post-crisis origin and the
post-crisis origin for the for the
controller's themselves what we end up
finding out is that we're originally you
had the Malthusians who basically
evolved to become the guardians of the
universe what we ended up having was
that some of them actually defected some
of them went away and basically the
male's broke off and what to do their
own thing and they became the
controllers they kind of
hyperaccelerated their own evolution and
manipulated their own structures
different things like that leading up to
their current state now the females left
and they became the zamarons they became
the star sapphires but the result is
that those individuals who stayed became
the guardians of the universe and so
that's kind of how those two groups
progressed but it is cool because the
controllers were always kind of
hell-bent on doing exactly what they
sound like controlling things and so
largely the controllers were enemies of
the Guardians and the Green Lantern's
and that was really about it now of
course the controllers also really made
there at least one of the big moments in
modern history when it came to really
the introduction of Larfleeze as the
orange lantern some of the controllers
had shown out trying to capture the
power of the orange lantern and they
were basically killed by Larfleeze and
that was really about it
but again the controllers as you've seen
them in the more recent stories of Green
Lantern's you know leading up to DC
rebirth and leading up to new 52 you
that's about the max that you got I mean
they're really reminiscent of an older
age of Green Lantern comics that people
don't really read about anymore and so
it is kind of intriguing but the basis
behind them kidnapping the Guardians is
that while they are their own subset of
a race now they do all stem from the
same thing and so genetically they are
pretty much identical they all stem from
the same genetic pool and so the logic
of the controllers is to basically find
a way to essentially strip the guardians
of their genetic material harvest them
more or less and then repopulate the
controllers because remember much like
the guardians it doesn't really seem
like the controllers are able to
procreate using traditional means and
even if they could they're all dudes so
I don't really know how you'd be able to
pull that off but the fact remains here
it is kind of cool because in response
to this of course the young the the new
Green Lantern the little kid Green
Lantern is asked by Jon Stewart what do
they look like the people that took you
know the the Guardians and the result is
that they end up just kind of showing
what their physical appearance was which
of course leads to the
trollers themselves and so of course you
know following this you basically have
this kind of all hands on deck everybody
jumping in trying to figure out what's
going on so on and so forth and it does
make sense I mean it really kind of
works in the sense that all the
guardians are just kind of responding as
we would expect but with Jon Stewart and
Guy Gardner in Hal Jordan and Kyle
Rayner it is kind of personal for them
because ganthet and sayd really sort of
represent this idea that the guardians
of the universe themselves are taking a
more traditional role more of a hands-on
role in the universe as opposed to being
shut off from it not only that the fact
that Jon Stewart returned with all the
Green Lantern's and then ganthet and
sayd kind of backed off and allowed him
to continue running the Green Lantern
Corps on its own does allow for a
measure of trust between the two groups
because one of the things you guys will
notice over the course of our you know
Sunday Green Lantern run is that for the
most part a lot of distrust is being
sowed between the guardians of the
universe and the Green Lantern's in the
sense of the Green Lantern's are slowly
beginning to realize the guardians of
the universe house many secrets and they
don't really tell a lot of the Green
Lantern's what are going on if they even
tell them at all it's one of those
things well you will learn what you need
to know when you need to know it and
that may or may not count now the other
half of this is you know once we jump
back in and the end the Templar
Guardians or at least some of the
Templar Guardians or being harvested
this is a way for Venditti in them to
basically begin winding down the number
of guardians to basically say we're
gonna start decreasing in a number
slowly but steadily and it does make
sense you know in the sense that this is
kind of their overarching or at least
his overarching goal assuming that's the
case because remember ganthet and sayd
being the OTL only guardians has
actually been a pretty popular theme in
the Green Lantern landscape for quite
some time just because of the fact that
the Guardians have always been a focal
point of a Green Lantern stories and in
a lot of ways it's one of those things
where all the stories that can be told
have been told and so if that's the case
then where do you go from there will you
simply change things up you switch
things around you move the pieces across
on the board and you switch players out
and you really just kind of try your
hand at making things starkly different
than they used to be and it actually
works now the other half of this is that
again I would surmise that with a lot of
these Templar guardians basically being
eliminated you know essentially being
removed the other reason for why it was
that they effectively vanished was
because it allowed Robert Van Didion
these guys really Sam Humphreys as well
to begin introducing characters like
Randy to basically say well I mean
here's the new origin of the Green
Lantern rings and all those kinds of
things and it does make sense you know
in terms of that again because of the
fact of these Templar guardians are kind
of just being eliminated I
don't really see us getting a whole lot
of exposition in terms of what the
Templar guardians are about where
they're from I imagine DC just kind of
relying and saying if you know who they
are cool if you don't don't worry about
it you know we just kind of end up
having to roll with the punches now of
course what the Green Lantern's
basically figuring out where the
controllers are operating from their
arrivals basically met with a handful of
mercenaries and again that's why I say
this is reminiscent of old-school Green
Lantern's storytelling because this is
what you would see and like the 60s 70s
and 80s man like some events taking
place where although good Green
Lantern's are gonna have to respond but
then he runs into an unexpected enemy
can he overcome them
yes he can now on to the main foe that's
basically how those stories were told
because DC rebirth is designed to wrap
back around to the old-school standard
of comic book storytelling more
adventure more fun as opposed to like
super serious grounded realistic
tangible stories because at the end of
the day comic books are designed to be
an escape or at least a lot of people
view them as isn't as an escape and so
that's really what this becomes I mean
for the love of God you've got John
Stuart a Green Lantern creating a
bazooka out of his ring and firing
rockets out of it I mean if that doesn't
scream spacefaring escapades and zonkers
storytelling I don't know what does I
have no idea what does now of course the
the Green Lantern's are able to overcome
these foes quite readily but the cool
thing about this is remember it's kind
of a return to what makes a Green
Lantern storytelling so well it's very
much forming this kind of camaraderie
and that was something that in a lot of
ways had kind of been missing from the
Green Lantern stories for a little while
in a lot of ways the characters kind of
fell rank-and-file but the idea of them
kind of coming together and saying okay
so like the four of us like the Four
Horsemen of the of the Green Lantern
landscape were the only ones who can
really pull this off it works and it's
really kind of a good feeling because it
brings you back to these old Green
Lantern stories back in the day now of
course the funny thing about this to you
is the controllers weren't really
betting on the Green Lantern's I mean
they they kind of say they were but they
were really expecting this idea that the
Green Lantern's would just kind of wait
for a sign from the Guardians or
something along those lines of course
the Green Lantern's respond and
basically just kind of start ripping
things up but remember it's not designed
to be this thing where it's like the
Green Lantern's are here and the day is
saved everybody's gonna lose now it
takes this familiarity of old-school
storytelling and it blends it in with
the modern-day Green Lantern stories
that were used to and that in and of
itself is the quintessential definition
of DC rebirth grab the old-school style
of storytelling combine it with the
modern-day characters that you're used
to
you merge them together and then just
see what happens and it is cool because
ultimately what is it happening is you
end up having this scenario where where
jon stewart who creates these a
reflection disc and then how Jordan
fires off a beam which in turn hits the
machine hoarding the gardens of the
universe captive which allows ganthet
and sayd and the other members to
basically arise and step in now again
you will notice characters like Ramy
here we're not really given a whole lot
here just because of the fact that
remember the Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern line of stories and the Green
Lantern's by Sam Humphreys those are
designed to be two distinctly different
lines of stories and so you know Rama's
basically been flushed out of course we
know he's the guy that created the
Phantom ring basically a lantern ring
that anybody can wield attached into the
entirety of the emotional spectrum but
it does kind of fit in in the sense that
if you're following Green Lantern's one
feeds the other you follow Green
Lantern's and then you jump in a house
run in the Green Lantern Corps and you
know who Ramy who that guy is
you know I'm figuring it out just like
everybody else is or you're reading Hal
Jordan in the Green Lantern Corps and
you're like who's a crazy-looking
Guardian and then you go on you read
Green Lantern's rebirth and you're like
okay so that's like one of the older
Guardians says that's really cool now
ultimately of course with the defeat of
the controllers they end up making their
escape and it's kind of funny because
one of the Guardians actually wants to
kill him you know Zola wants to kill off
the controllers which is actually the
most logical stance to take gaff it
really kind of being in a position where
he's like the new role that we play is
more of being Guardians as opposed to
being like authoritative figures for the
universe we can't let this happen like
we can't just kill them they have to
stand trial assuming that we can catch
them again and so that's the result
because what then did he does is he
basically says the controllers are back
now the controllers are going to return
to becoming enemies of the Green
Lantern's now again this is just kind of
grabbing on an older enemy and rolling
them in to DC Comics and so following
this well we end up finding out in this
epilogue of sorts is that one the
guardians of the universe go back to
their original outfits which is to say
basically the red the white and the
Green Lantern uniform not only that the
Templar Guardians have kind of stepped
out of their role of just kind of
exploring the universe and are now back
to being the guardians of the universe
and so it's basically then did he sing
okay
so the guardians of the universe are
back different people are playing roles
who were occupied by former guardians
who are now gone but they're gonna go
back to being the classic guardians of
the universe and it works again this is
what DC rebirth is it's a return to
familiarity is grabbing all the old
things that you remember when you were
when you were seven eight nine ten years
old and you were reading these comics
it's designed to grab those things and
bring them all back in and so it's cool
and and it really really works not only
that we end up finding out that the
controllers are basically bringing back
an older enemy again Michael I'm Michael
Jan Friedrich introduced these guys back
in 1992 they're bringing back the dark
stars the dark stars are cool the dark
stars are really really cool
they are basically kind of like this
this merging of the Manhunters and the
Green Lanterns kind of combine into one
it was really the attempt of the
controllers to create their own version
of the Green Lantern's or own police
force and then just sort of go forward
for man
okay so continuing on with our whole ECE
birthing and Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern Corps this one is actually
pretty interesting this mind game
stories actually kind of cool because
what you guys will find those are guys
who are new to comic books what you're
gonna find is that in a lot of ways
stories are usually designed to kind of
wrap up loose ends especially when
you're going into high ends or when
you're going into like a major event or
something along those lines now for the
most part DC is very different from
Marvel Marvel does here's line wide
crossover events seemingly all the time
which is one of the reasons why people
developed a vent fatigue DC really plays
it more close to the best in the sense
that you usually have character based
story arcs but it's one of these funny
scenarios because it's kind of like you
know all this has happened before and
all of it will happen again to quote
Battlestar Galactica it is kind of cool
because what this actually does is it
invokes Hector Hammond but it also comes
after the Superman story that dealt with
Superman getting possessed by parallax
now again that was kind of cool because
it was one of these scenarios or it sort
of dealt with the ongoing events as a
whole in DC rebirth and that's one of
the reasons why rebirth is so important
here is because when it came to like the
new 52 which is when DC rebooted in 2011
they said look you want you to act like
we've never printed stories for the very
first you know you never print them
before you've never seen Superman Batman
or anything you want you to treat them
like they're brand new the funny thing
about that was that some of the stories
crossed over but by and large a lot of
the titles were largely isolated they
were basically kind of like doing their
own thing you'd see other references but
with DC rebirth what is really designed
to do is effectively say yes they are in
a shared universe yes some of these
events are happening at the same time
but what happens in one comic will cross
over into another either directly or
indirectly you don't see it all the time
but it does create some really really
good consistency when it comes to
continuity and that's one of the really
important things because DC had a
branding initiative called DC U and it
was basically creativity over continuity
it was where a DC editorial basically
went to the riders who said whatever you
want don't worry about the continuity of
what goes on in other stories and you
started seeing weird things where you
had like that man who was the god of you
know God of knowledge when it came to
you the Justice League title but in his
own title Bruce Wayne was a Batman it
was Commissioner Gordon and so he kind
of ran into all these different you know
continuity errors different things like
that but the cool thing was that with
regards to DC rebirth and the Superman
story you dealt with the return of
parallax this living embodiment of fear
more or less
the idea of parallax showing up was
really just kind of d3 - hey parallax is
here parallax is still very much part of
the landscape but we also saw that
Sinestro had kind of made his return for
the purpose of tracking down the
parallax entity and trying to take it
for himself kind of trying to re you
know regain its abilities and go back to
his status quo this follows after that
and basically saying that after the
whole fiasco of the return of parallax
because most all of Earth's superheroes
are familiar with who parallax is the
Green Lantern Corps is notified I
remember you know one of the things is
pointed out here and it's these really
small things that I really kind of enjoy
about DC rebirth especially when it
comes to vanities riding it is really
one of these things where sidewalk
contacts the the Green Lantern Corps and
says anything outside of Earth's solar
system is your call and because of the
fact that parallax as a as the fear
entity is really kind of like part and
parcel to the Green Lantern landscape is
effectively handed over to them and so
the result is that Jon Stewart who's
basically head of the Green Lantern
Corps dispatches one of their number
back to earth now it's kind of funny
because Earth has like six Green
Lantern's basically Jon Stewart who's of
Earth you got Kyle Rayner who's of Earth
Hal Jordan as well as Jessica Cruz and
Simon bass so you've got like six Green
Lantern's that all hail from Earth which
is not something you normally see it's
one of the cool aspects of the
publication history of a Green Lantern
mythos but of course Hal Jordan being
the star of the Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps comic is the one that sent
to Earth the fact remains you know with
Hal Jordans showing up of course he
basically meets with Superman and
Superman essentially explains everything
that had happened in the Superman story
and again that's why this is so cool and
that's why Venditti is so awesome when
it comes to this kind of a thing is
because when it comes to his stories
whether it's a six-issue arc whether
it's a seven issue arc or even just a
two issue arc it's basically here's a
quick recap over the course of one page
about everything that's happened so far
so you don't feel left out especially if
you're someone that's not really a huge
fan of the Superman comics but you do
love Green Lantern the last thing you're
looking for is to be put in a position
where you have to go and read a comic
book that you're not wildly a fan of
just to understand what's going on at
the moment so it's kind of cool you know
Venditti gives us just enough to tell us
what's going on but also what's the
appetite of that of the average cover
book reader and say hey look maybe you
do want to go check that out where
Superman becomes possessed by parallax
which of course if you are interested I
have a video on that so feel free to
check it out down in the description but
again what we saw in that story was that
Superman had taken the ring of Sinestro
and then confined the parallel
entity to it the problem with this is
that how Jordan suddenly starts kind of
hearing this voice in his head and then
immediately has this image of Superman
becoming parallax and it actually kind
of breaks out into a really awesome
fight between the two now in truth this
is one of those things that people kind
of debate from time to time and DC
Comics is almost always referenced that
the Green Lantern ring is the most
powerful device in the universe not
necessarily because of its durability or
anything like that but because the
constructs that can be created by Green
Lantern are limited only to the mind of
the Green Lantern and we've seen that
progress over the years in DC Comics you
know when you have the original Green
Lantern Allen Scott things are pretty
basic he was kind of creating these
small little constructs here and there
they got a little more advanced when how
Jordan was introduced he had a giant
boxing glove he had like wrenches but it
really kind of exploded in the realm of
creativity with the introduction of Kyle
Rayner II he would create these giant
mecca's and he's huge you know I guess
super advanced looking constructs and it
was really interesting but it really
always had home at the idea that the
constructs created by the Green
Lantern's are left to the imagination of
the Green Lantern's now remember that
does not mean that constructs are
indestructible there's a difference
between a limitless imagination and how
those constructs can be made and the
indestructible nature of the constructs
constructs can be destroyed we've seen
that happen before
a being of sufficient strength even
Superman himself can break out of the
constructs of Green Lantern's if they're
powerful enough now this is cool because
in the battles that we've seen you know
especially when it came to something
like MMO Twilight parallax wrecked
Superman in that story well you're
talking about how Jordan who was so
incredibly powerful that he was a
universal threat when it comes to just
traditional Hal Jordan with his Green
Lantern constructs you know and just
kind of fighting Superman for the most
part Superman will usually win and even
then it depends on what kind of stories
you're talking about for example in the
original Justice League story from the
new 52 the first six issues story arc
how Jordan went to go face off against
Superman and got wrecked and that
version of Superman is not as powerful
as the rebirth Superman that we have
flowing around right now but one he's
fighting at the moment as parallax and
so for the most part this fight should
be no contest in a lot of ways but one
thing I want you guys to notice is that
it does seem to be a contest Superman is
not necessarily getting the upper hand
here and the reason why the reason this
is taking place is because what are we
end up finding out is this version of
Superman as parallax is an illusion it's
not actually happening for whatever
reason which well you know what
talk about here in a second pal Jordan's
mind is basically being messed with in
reality he just suddenly attacked
Superman Superman's cometh what are you
doing and he was fighting on the
defensive that's why how Jordan wasn't
totally obliterated here because in Hal
Jordans mind it was oh my god Oh
Superman as parallax I've gotta defeat
him whereas Superman wasn't fighting to
kill him Superman was fighting it
self-defense and so it was really more
of just trying to neutralize him if he
can so again it's kind of funny but we
end up finding out that these mind games
that are being played on Hal Jordan are
actually being done by Hector Hammond
now this idea of Hector Hammond in this
story I should all we treat to it tweets
a Venditti about this and ask him what's
going on this whole idea of Hector
Hammond in DC rebirth is kind of
intriguing because we can take this one
of two different ways we can basically
say that everything we saw in the new 52
with Hector Hammond is irrelevant none
of it matters I would say this is
probably classic Hector Hammond and the
reason why is because even before the
new 52 Hector Hammond had two different
organs the original origin of Hector
Hammond was that he was basically just a
guy who came across the ship of a
bansuri you know the guy who basically
passed his Lantern ring on to Hal Jordan
and Hector Hammond was just kind of hit
with the radiation of the ship and it
caused his brain to swell up and he
gained you know additional powers if you
go and you look at the original origin
of Hector Hammond from way back in the
day when he first showed up he
encountered a meteorite and that's
really about it so there's two different
versions there now of course the one
with him coming into contact with the
ship of a banned sewer that is the
secret origin of Green Lantern from
Geoff Johns so for the most part that's
the most recent origin of Hector Hammond
that's probably the one that we can go
with but even then when we saw the
stories of you know Green Lantern as it
was taken over by Geoff Johns what
basically happened here is we were
introduced to the idea that Hector
Hammond gaining this sort of enhanced
intellect things like that but it was a
circumstance that was set in play it
wasn't a roll of the dice it wasn't like
he just kind of happened to work out
that way it was one of these things
where things were kind of engineered in
a particular position so that this sort
of experiment that was done by these
gremlins of sorts would eventually play
itself out and so the result is that
Hector Hammond is really more of a lab
rat if anything else and these gremlins
you're seeing here seem to be kind of a
throwback a return to familiarity with
Hector Hammond in regards to Geoff Johns
run of Green Lantern now remember when
it comes to the whole Green Lantern
thing those of you guys who were new to
all this when it comes to Green Lantern
it can be a little confusing which is
one of the reasons why we're kind of
catching up with it all and we're
getting it all sorted out but the whole
with this is you basically have
everything before Jeff Jones when it
comes to green lantern everything before
green lantern rebirth the original story
where you basically had you know the
return of how Jordan there were a few
stories that took place before that the
last will and testament of Hal Jordan
for example the story power of ion with
regards to Kyle Rayner you know all
these different things that kind of went
in there but with the exception of the
smattering of stories by Joe Kelly and
different things like that by and large
you can basically just say plot with
Green Lantern rebirth and read
everything after but regardless of how
it is this is playing out because of the
fact that Hector Hammond was the one
that forced the mind of Hal Jordan into
hallucinating that Superman had become
parallax it gets the attention of how
Jordan he just kind of realizes what's
going on now he'll join a Superman
showing up they faced off against these
gremlins and they defeat him quick fast
and in a hurry it's not a great big huge
thing at least that seems to be the case
but what these gremlins are now doing is
they basically kind of jumpstart the
mind of Hector Hammond in the sense that
all these electrodes have been put in
place to allow them to control it to a
degree now this has really Venditti kind
of introducing new DC rebirth readers to
Hector Hammond in terms of what he's
capable of and why it is that he can be
so powerful what is up happening here is
with regards to Hal Jordan he's
basically kind of thrown into this
mental simulation of sorts where
everything he wanted could basically
come true and that's one of the reasons
why this is so intriguing worse not
necessarily how Jordan's father whose
return from a dad or anything like that
he basically envisions a life with like
Carol Ferris putting time with his
brother and his his sister-in-law and
you know hanging out with their kids as
someone who's so fourth mouth in truth
for those of you guys who were
experienced with Green Lantern even
those of guys who are not experienced
with Green Lantern the father of how
Jordan plays a major role in his life in
the sense that everything how Jordan
does is really kind of predicated on the
question what would my father do and so
if his father were suddenly brought back
from the dead and the motivation for Hal
Jordan getting to the place where he is
now would be irrevocably different the
basis behind it would be totally changed
the fact that his father died when he
was younger was the motivation for how
Jordan becoming a pilot in the first
place it's one of those things he can't
get it can't really get rid of I mean
it's like eliminating the destruction of
Krypton it's saying well Krypton never
blew up you know well then what reason
would there be for Superman to show up
on earth but those of the guys who are
new to Green Lantern and not familiar
with this Carol Ferris was a long time
on again/off again love interest of Hal
Jordan she eventually became the first
star sapphire which is to say basically
a group of lanterns that were formed by
the zamarons
who believe that love is the greatest
thing ever those
who are of other members of the lantern
cores you know the Sinestro Corps
something like that the zamarons will
take them and try to convert them into
star sapphires but it's kind of an
interesting scenario in terms of how
that plays out but while that love is
kind of on-again off-again really in DC
we berth we haven't seen hide nor hair
of Carol Ferris and this is a really big
thing when it comes to people who are
existing Green Lantern fans so this was
really kind of like the first you know
indication that we get about her
character and about what she's about the
problem with this is that for Hal Jordan
his mind immediately picks up on the
fact that none of this is right and this
really feeds into the willpower of Hal
Jordan in the sense that in order for
the Green Lantern's to be effective they
have to basically tap into their own
willpower and overcome everything love
fear the whole nine yards and so with
that in mind he really just overpowers
this mental image to a degree breaks out
of it you know and where Superman's
still kind of fighting alongside the
whole thing hallucinating his own
parents and he breaks out of the tube
we're right back into the fray we're
right back into the conflict now of
course before anything really goes crazy
too bad Hector Hammond kills all the
gremlins that are present that's really
about it
but again it is kind of cool because
this is bringing back a character that
we haven't really seen for some time of
course Hector Hammond kind of seizes on
the mind of a Superman tries to get
Superman to take him out to basically
you know kill Hector Hammond himself it
is kind of intriguing into this cool
because it's this great villain who's
kind of making his return or at least
that seems to be the case I mean
ultimately he's basically kind of throw
back a throw back into STAR Labs they
sort of keep him there and it's like
well these electrodes are in his brain
that we don't know what effect they have
we don't even know if they can be
removed we're just gonna go ahead and
kind of leave them there now this is
cool because what it does is it teases
the possibility that Hector Hammond can
come back more powerful than he ever was
before so kind of boosts the abilities
of Hector Hammond going forward in DC
rebirth that's one of the trends that I
hope you guys are noticing when it comes
to the DC rebirth landscape is that it's
really kind of serving the purpose of
either taking existing heroes amplifying
them and taking them back to their
original roots or bringing back
old-school villains and so it was kind
of interesting because all these
villains are kind of coming out of the
woodwork which is one of the reasons why
I say DC rebirth is kind of leading up
to a crisis it'll basically be like the
Watchmen or dr. Manhattan versus the DC
Universe there's two three your plan
that DC has will eventually hit its
finality and when it does it'll be some
great big huge massive event and then DC
you'll say and now we're done and so now
what we've done here will be the
foundation for the future of DC Comics I
mean again it's just really kind of
Grammys
things and sort of you know trying to
trying to grab the clues in the bits and
pieces now again the idea of Carol
Ferris basically being returned to the
DC landscape comes by way of Hal Jordan
traveling to her house with the
intention of actually trying to rekindle
this romance the problem with this is
he's called off by John Stewart of the
Green Lantern's ultimately bails on the
decision and really just kind of takes
off and so again it's Vendetti basically
saying hey look all these classic
characters from the Green Lantern run
Carol Farah is Hector Hammond different
means like that they're all still there
they will make their returns they will
reappear it's just a matter of time
before they do okay so we are getting
into a really kind of picking up again
with Hal Jordan the Green Lantern Corps
it's been a little while since we
covered cover this this part of DC
rebirth but this basically picks up with
Zod's will this is kind of like you know
basically General Zod wrecking the Green
Lantern which is actually pretty awesome
but something that I do want to talk
about here for a second is the nature of
Kryptonian powers because I've seen this
question asked before so one of the
questions that I've that I've seen it's
actually a really really good question
if Kryptonians absorbs solar radiation
shouldn't Supergirl basically be exactly
as powerful to Superman like if you took
50 Kryptonians and you set them on a
singular planet then should they all be
equally as powerful like none is more
powerful than the other and if that's
true then why is it a Supergirl is more
powerful than Superman why is General
Zod less powerful in Superman okay so
these aren't you some really really good
questions and they're they're a really
cool idea what this does is begin to
kind of answer it but the whole idea was
Supergirl to kind of address that for a
second pre-crisis which is to say up
until 1985 there was no answer to that
it was just super girls more powerful
than Superman because reasons and and
that was basically it
post crisis that was answered by Geoff
Johns I'm pretty sure back in the mid
2000s where Kara zor-el first showed up
after the events of crisis on Infinite
Earths and the explanation DC offered
was that when she was held in suspended
animation basically she had like solar
radiation bombarding her while she was
in her spacecraft and so she had
essentially been absorbing solar
radiation for a much longer time than
Superman that's one of the big reasons
why there's a differentiating factor
with General Zod he was consistently
shown to have been weaker because he was
constantly catching up he had been
locked in the Phantom Zone
what will you he was supposed to be in
there for eternity but he even locked to
the Phantom Zone for a very long time
and so while Superman was absorbing
solar radiation on earth the General Zod
was just sitting in the Phantom Zone
with knows no seeming you know no way to
escape basically until he
and so that's why General Zod has
consistently shown to be somewhere near
Superman's power or lower than Superman
he's not really shown to be Leo more
powerful than Superman so hopefully that
kind of cleared things up but what this
does is this basically picks up in the
aftermath of the whole battle with the
controllers now of course the
controllers will return especially with
your the the return of the dark stars
but again because of the fact of the
controllers were a group of mountains
who basically went off and did their own
thing and became a wholly separate group
from the guardians of the universe
themselves the controllers kind of went
on this campaign to kidnap the Guardians
to convert them basically to Reem
aterial eyes them more or less or kind
of SAP their energy and create more
controllers to kind of bring controllers
back what this did is it led to you know
Jon Stewart and Hal Jordan and so on and
so forth the various Green Lantern's
rescuing the guardians of the universe
and so what this means is that the
guardians are basically reforming into
their previous roles but this is a very
iffy situation and the reason for this
is because remember when it came to
everything before the new 52 basically
the old Geoff Johns run the guardians of
the universe were shown to have been a
group that was very manipulative and
housed a lot of Secrets they didn't tell
the the Green Lantern's everything they
wanted to know and when it can't when it
comes to like Jon Stewart he initially
quits and he basically decides to quit
in the face of the Reformation of the
guardians of the universe and of course
the question that kind of have is but
why though Jon Stewart basically says
the last time we had a quote-unquote neo
council of the guardians of the universe
you guys hid information you guys
ignored the warning signs of the coming
you know destruction of the of the
universe and it took view the rise of
the black Lantern's
in order of you guys to finally realize
things were popping off it was the idea
that the guardians had become very
tyrannical and so the result is that
when Jon Stewart looks at the
Reformation of the guardians of the
universe his whole idea is we're going
back to the way things used to be and I
don't want to be a part of that now
here's kind of the cool thing ganthet
and sayd our old school right they're
basically the original guardians of the
universe all the original guardians
except for those two are basically dead
it's a whole new group of guardians who
were there but this is basically a fresh
face a fresh group of people with the
exception of ganthet ganthet and sayd
but their whole response is the fact
that you realize Jon Stewart that this
is a problem is why we need you here we
don't want to become the council that
becomes despotic we want someone to be
able to keep us in check and so it's
kind of cool because it's basically
meeting halfway and so of course he's
basically sent back out by the Guardians
he's told to essentially just kind of
make sure everything is in check and
then of course they tell him hey look
there's a crisis
Sector somewhere and you gotta send some
lanterns to check it out so of course
because this is Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern Corps Hal Jordan Kyle Rayner
respond now when they get here there's
basically a race here that's kind of in
the in the Stone Age but they're
essentially building like this massive
kind of citadel of Swiss and we end up
finding out all this is being
orchestrated by General Zod now this is
a very important thing because General
Zod is immediately attacked by Hal
Jordan and Kyle Rayner and that's
important because they launched the
first strike General Zod did not do
anything to provoke this attack he was
simply just there now in reality it's
because General Zod is a Kryptonian bad
guy he always has been he's always done
these really really crabby terrible
things but at the moment he's not done
anything wrong and so in reality what
you really have here is Hal Jordan and
company showing up on the doorstep of
General Zod whether they knew it or not
and then saying you're coming with us
with nothing to actually charge him with
and so in response General Zod actually
breaks free of the constructs of Hal
Jordan now in truth this shouldn't
normally be allowed to happen but what
we end up finding out here is this
planet is orbiting two yellow Suns and
so what this means is that General Zod
has been absorbing twice the amount of
solar radiation that he normally has
general Zod's power level has been
jumped forward and that's why we had
this discussion at the beginning of the
video it's because we're General Zod has
been consistently catching up with
Superman in the sense that like you know
Superman gets you know he just kind of
has this level of power and sometimes he
cuts loose sometimes he doesn't General
Zod has always just been a little bit
weaker because he was exposed to solar
radiation later than Superman was but
being in a location where he's absorbing
twice the radiation he's basically
catching up to Superman very very very
fast and at the moment right now he's
equal to Superman in power and so not
only that and again not only do we have
General Zod here but going back to like
the action comics line of stories of
Superman line of stories
well you had like a radicand so on and
so forth Zod still has his own little
miniature army so he's got his wife he's
got his son and he's got the Eradicator
kind of like this this old piece of
Kryptonian technology is really what he
is but this leads to a conflict between
Kyle Rayner and Hal Jordan himself now
this is very important here because what
ends up happening is you basically have
the wife of General Zod who's as
powerful as Superman General Zod himself
who's as powerful as Superman their son
who's as powerful and the Eradicator Hal
Jordan Kyle Rayner do not stand a chance
and they literally get absolutely
decimated with the greatest of ease I
mean they are laid waste to in an
instant but in the aftermath of the two
of them being captured of course they
we shipped with their rings and they're
you know at least house one is taken
before general zod now this is kind of a
funny thing here when it comes to Zod as
a care of this one the reasons why I
always liked him so much historically
speaking when it comes to comics you
know that good good guys are good guys
bad guys are bad guys what makes bad
guys interesting are the motivations
behind what they do what they do or why
they do what they do but also like who
they are and how they're inherently
written some bad guys are just bad guys
like electro was never really an
interesting villain in the spider-man
mythos until he like took down power to
the raff and freed all the super
villains but like magneto has always
been interesting because his character
has evolved and changed so much over the
years
General Zod is much the same way when
Hal Jordan is brought before Zod
it's not so Zod could just start
pummeling him and saying tell me what I
want to know it's because Zod is just
kind of like let's sit down and have a
conversation let's talk now in reality
how Jordans just kind of like I don't
want to hear you're a bad guy you got to
go that's what the reasons why this is
interesting in the way that it's written
because you look at this and how Jordan
almost seems to be like the antagonist
here whereas you just kind of has
General Zod here on this planet now
because that is a villain you can't help
but wonder what it is that he's up to
but it is kind of intriguing now the
other half of this is that General Zod
does not know how the ring of Hal Jordan
works the ring that Hal Jordan wields
right now is not the ring that he
historically wielded how Jordan forged
his ring out of pure willpower it's part
and parcel to himself
basically how Jordan's ring is like his
arm or his leg or his brain or something
along those lines and so because it's
tied inherently to his willpower he's
able to literally command the ring and
have it break directly out of its cell
and return to Him and so what he ends up
doing is basically flying back to Kyle
Rayner and this is when we realized that
when it comes to like this group here
the script that it's believed that that
General Zod is kind of oppressing and
forcing into slave labor it's not
actually that way instead these guys
worship General Zod now this kind of
invokes a whole idea of like the Star
Trek prime directive right I mean like
like if you're in Star Trek universe the
prime directive is you cannot interact
with races that have not achieved
interstellar travel you have to allow
them to continue on their own their own
path until they eventually discover
faster-than-light travel and then from
there you know then you can interact
them with this whole situation here it's
this idea if we start messing around
with these guys if we start causing
problems then what we basically do here
is we kind of obstruct the progression
of this race but this race looks at
General Zod sees him as a guy who can
fly who's got like super speed strength
so on and so with MA
him as a God and the result is that they
worship Him as a god and Zod has
essentially been using that to get them
to do work for him he's not been forcing
them into oppression if anything he's
kind of manipulating it but manipulating
someone is not any illegal act he hasn't
actually done anything wrong here and so
the result is that with General Zod is
kind of okay look you know we got to
take care of these two Green Lantern's
Hal Jordan essentially like binds his
ring directly to Kyle Rayner
transforming him into something akin to
like an infinite lantern basically and
then sending Kyle Rayner back to back to
OA and so it's kind of cool because Kyle
Rayner is actually bond a bonded with
pure willpower now the problem with this
is that because it is such an extreme
level of power
Kyle's trying to adapt to it but this
power this this pure willpower that he's
getting it's actually like kind of
overriding his senses and what I mean by
that is that he's suffering from like a
lacerated liver he's got broken ribs by
all standards of measurement he should
be like recovering and in surgery right
now
but this willpower he's receiving is
kind of amplifying him up to the extreme
we're just like overrides all those
sensations and so basically he feels no
pain he's just totally gassed up and
ready to go the other funny thing about
this is because because of the fact that
he's bonded with Hal Jordans willpower
he's spouting off Hal Jordan quotes he's
saying things Al Jordan would say but at
this point we kind of switch back over
to that to the guardians of the universe
themselves and again this is why the
whole situation with Jon Stewart is
somewhat tenuous because Jon Stewart is
getting what he wanted he's just
realized that it's not really what he
wanted basically what he's getting is
not what he had hoped for it what the
guardians of the universe and back in
the old days they would have just been
like Gogan Hal Jordan done and that
would have been it and they would have
said get him back by any means necessary
you know you have leave to do whatever
you have to do and they would have
fought General Zod it would have been
kind of a cool battle for a few minutes
and then they would have won they woulda
brought Hal Jordan count me all grunt
Hal Jordan back with this new guardians
a new guardian council their whole
stance is we can't be so quick to
judgment and so we basically have to
deliberate and for John Stuart it's so
frustrating because it's like but it's
one of our lantern stuff and that's kind
of the big differentiating factor
between the guardians of the universe
and like normal people a normal human
being is basically primitive like we're
pretty basic we're pretty emotional
we're not that bright in the grand
scheme of things like people have a
tendency to let their emotions override
their common sense and so with that in
mind the guardians is kind of like okay
but like you know I realize that you
want to go get Hal Jordan but like
you're an idiot though because like
you're very emotional and you're not as
wise as we are
cuz we've been around for like a like
three billion years or something along
those lines so like let our 3 billion
years of wisdom kind of play out here
and then when you've been alive for
three billion years and you can kind of
play that role you know when 900 years
you reach you know look how good you
know look good you will not or whatever
the hell it was you order said that Luke
Skywalker so with this whole thing
John's kind of response is but we have
to rescue how though and this is one of
the reasons why John Stuart is so cool
but also one of the reasons why the the
kind of antagonistic nature of the Green
Lantern's and the the guardians of the
universe works so well because a lot of
the agreement were really the earthbound
Green Lantern's for the most part want
to have their cake and eat it too we
need to be logical we to think things
out unless it's something I really
really want then we should just do that
but like if it's not something that what
I did I really really want well then
yeah just let things play out and we'll
just kind of see what happens I mean
it's one of those things we can't have
it both ways
and so the result is that John Stuart
kind of takes off but he does exactly
what you would expect he'd do Guy
Gardner of course die garner being Guy
Gardner basically goes in grabs you know
are kind of a core member of the Green
Lantern's that says we got to go rescue
Hal Jordan and then essentially takes
off and Jon Stewart's like I didn't see
anything as it was kind of interesting
here because what what's happening the
entire time this is going on is Kyle
weiners ring is still with General Zod
and so General Zod is actually going
through and having the Eradicator
analyzed the ring but of course then all
the Green Lantern's show up and they
basically end up facing off against
General Zod now again with Kyle Rayner
wielding essentially the the power of
two Green Lantern's it is kind of cool
here because when he shows up it is an
extreme level of willpower that he has
at his disposal and for the most part
he's able to hold his own to a degree
the problem with this is that again
you're talking about Kryptonians that
are twice as powerful as they normally
are not only that they're actually
fighting with restraints they're just
kind of like hey like hold back a little
bit and let's just kind of see what
happens unless let's just sort of keep
them at bay because what they're doing
is basically stalling that's really all
they're doing here and that's kind of
interesting because when you're watching
these Kryptonians stall against the
Green Lantern's yet still hold their own
against the Green Lantern's the question
has to become so like what happens when
they go when they go ham like what
happens when he just like flat-out loses
it and so for a minute General Zod does
that when he literally like punches out
Kyle Rayner and sends him flying and
that's why I say this is so awesome
because it kind of gives us like this
full brunt concept of like what would
happen if a full-on Kryptonian faced off
against a Green Lantern and that
Kryptonian is just like basically
Superman a level power with no no real
reason to hold back this is a pretty
cool moment here because how do how do
Orton kind of reaches out and says look
you can't keep tampering with this power
like I gave it to you so you can get
away but you have no idea what impact
this level of power is gonna have on
your body you don't know if it'll kill
you and so for a minute how Jordan like
what he actually does is he kind of you
know tries to reason with with Kyle and
then basically strips a--'s willpower
back from Cobb reverting him to his
normal form kind of amplifies it a bit
and then in turn like grabs his
willpower brings it back and his ring
returns to himself and then of course
you know Hal Jordan arrives on the scene
now of course this is after like all the
Kryptonians have decimated all the other
Green Lantern's so it's really one of
these things where like Hal Jordan is
the last man standing now again when
you're talking about Hal Jordan fighting
here against General Zod it's kind of a
continuation of that whole discussion
that we had earlier well of course
General Zod being as powerful as
Superman he crushed Hal Jordan before
you should be able to crush him now but
it doesn't work that way because what
house one kind of says here is look I
wasn't prepared to fight a Kryptonian
who who had been exposed to this much
solar radiation I didn't expect to see
you fighting here and now it's one of
those coming book hop outs it works but
it's one of those things that writers
kind of use to sort of adjust the story
a little bit but in turn like is it's
basically the willpower of Hal Jordan
facing off against the full power of
General Zod essentially facing off
against Superman here and it's awesome
because the ring allows a person to do
whatever they want to do it allows their
imagination to run wild but the ring is
only as powerful as the willpower of the
person who wields it but was cut with
with Hal Jordan is a wholly separate
circumstance because the ring is an
extension of himself actually the ring
is his willpower it's not just a thing
that was given to him and so he's
basically fighting with his mind body
and soul and that's why this is so cool
is because he's able to hold his own
pretty damn well against General Zod and
actually able to like beat the crap out
of him now
the other thing to remember here is that
General Zod is a master strategist the
issue with General Zod is that by and
large most of his battles have been
confined to Superman or like Wonder
Woman or something along those lines
because he's historically been a
Superman villain
Superman is more of just like hardcore
punching in different things like that
and kind of thinking about things from a
different perspective but that's always
been the nature of Zod versus Superman
the military strategist versus the guy
who just punches things and so when it
comes to this whole situation
Hal Jordan his experience when it comes
to like various forms of military combat
is he is well-versed in this not only
that he thinks about things with a
little bit more imagination and the
reason why I say this is that when he's
facing off against odd and sending all
these different you know
these have been hard like constructs in
the form of like Jets toward him General
Zod is kind of thinking about it in a
two dimensional space there's there's
front and there's back what Hal Jordan
however he just kind of sits around and
he says one of the most important things
the Air Force taught me is that there is
no real up-and-down I mean there's up
and down and so much you have a brown in
the sky but like fights are
three-dimensional and so you have to see
things around you at all times and so
that's when Zod begins to turn around
and realize that like all these
different things are coming at him from
every single direction now it's not
enough to destroy Zod but it is enough
to take him by surprise and that's a
pretty significant feat because when
that happens it basically allows Howard
you want to take him prisoner now as
soon as this happens the Green Lantern's
pop up and say you have to let him go he
hasn't actually broken any laws here so
there's nothing that we can do because
then he's essentially let go here but
it's kind of cool because general Zod's
response is we don't want you here now
this is the biggest motivation for why
General Zod is doing all this no the
whole Corps the whole purpose of General
Zod the whole way he perceives us is
that tomorrow a was the Green Lantern of
the sector that Krypton was in when
Krypton blew up and so Zod has always
held a hatred for Green Lantern's
because of the simple fact that the
Green Lantern that he perceives that
that tomar way had failed a tomar ray
had basically screwed up in a loud
Krypton to be destroyed and so in his
mind he's like we rebuke your
protections like do whatever you want to
do in this sector but do not come here
and it works because what it means is
that he would be able to sort of
function with autonomy that nobody can
really interfere and what it is that he
has going on the other half of this is
that for Zod the reason why he was
analyzing the Ring of Power which of
course would return the Col Rayner and
you know they were all kind of allowed
to go free is that what Zod wanted was
the information stored inside the Ring
which no one really seemed to ask the
question of what he was doing with the
ring but what Zod was doing going
through in analyzing the ring he
essentially has a map of the universe
now he has a map of every single race in
the universe every single planet in the
universe the weapons capabilities of
those races on those planets how many
Green Lantern's are are where the Green
Lantern's are stationed at all the
goings on that exist inside the universe
right now and what it means is he has
every conceivable piece of information
he would need from a military strategic
standpoint that's a gold mine if you're
a military strategist and you can know
what the enemy's weapons are you can
know where the weapons are and you can
know how to attack those weapons without
being seen you've basically won the war
especially if they don't know that you
have that information because you can
you can implement
that in any conceivable way that you
want to and so what this does right now
is it makes General Zod quite possibly
the most dangerous being in the universe
but something else that I want you guys
to consider this is kind of a war this
is kind of an interesting scenario
because it sort of points of the idea of
what direction Hal Jordan might be going
in it's one panel it's not very long but
but Hal Jordan starts talking to Jon
Stewart about the idea of ending
villains permanently he's just kind of
like what do you think about the idea
that like if we got rid of villains like
if we face up against the villain and
they were gone for good
would that really be a bad thing and in
reality it wouldn't a dead man cannot be
a repeat offender Hal Jordan is not
really wrong here
it's not necessarily the worst idea to
kill every criminal who commits a crime
the problem with this is like evidence
and and different things like that it is
kind of interesting you know and it kind
of points at the idea that Hal Jordan
sort of falling down this road of
possibly becoming a bad guy
we don't really know okay so we are
covering Hal Jordan and the Green
Lantern Corps and this is like the
next-to-last story arc if the
solicitations are to be believed then
basically Hal Jordan the Green Lantern
Corps will end at issue number 50 I
think Green Lantern's is ending at the
same issue and they're both going to
combine what they're gonna do with the
rest of the titles I don't really know
but for some reason DC has an affinity
for the number 52 right it was like new
52 they have 52 universes when new 52
kicked off all the issues ran for 52
issues until DC rebirth happened DC
loves the number 52 it's like the number
seven from Harry Potter
but anyway what this does is this
initially picks up with well really with
the dark stars now the whole idea of the
of the dark stars the the basis behind
them is that in the early 1990s round 9
22 I think it was DC was trying to find
a way to reinvigorate the interest and
the Green Lantern stories because
remember we talked about this and how
Jordan explained from you know two years
ago whenever it was but Hal Jordan
despite the fact that he alongside Barry
Allen had helped to reinvigorate
interest in comic books in the 1950s he
basically dropped off on popularity
relatively fast like within ten years he
was not very popular at all and in fact
he was a backup feature in the flash for
a while and so before DC had the idea to
kill him off and to I guess to get rid
of Hal Jordan to basically ride him out
with the whole event of Emerald Twilight
one of the things they did was create
the dark stars and the dark stars were
gonna be this sort of like new core so
think of it as akin to what Geoff Johns
did with all the lantern course before
Geoff Johns and they were basically
created by a group called the
controllers well
talk a little about the controller's
here in a second but back then in the
90s the controllers were just like an
offshoot of the guardians of the
universe they were just they were all
now Tuesdays at one point but they had
just gone a different direction
they become a lot more reclusive and a
lot more extreme and heavy-handed in
terms of how they believe the order or
the universe should be governed instead
of having the Green Lantern's as a
police force as a peacekeeping force the
dark stars were really extremists in a
lot of ways now of course this
eventually sort of began to fall to the
wayside after the events of Emerald
Twilight and of course DC started going
into new crises with Infinite Crisis and
Final Crisis and so on and so forth but
the return of the dark stars here in DC
rebirth what vinda t's doing is is
making them a little more extreme and
simply saying that they have taken up
this mantle by way of the controller's
yet again the difference is that where
the dark stars used to operate under the
control of the controllers now they
operate independently they basically use
the controllers for their own ends
harnessing their psychic powers and then
functioning as their own core more or
less and instead of being like the Green
Lantern's where they function and more
of a peacekeeping capacity they're
basically all like the Punisher they
just kill everyone in this instance what
had happened is tomar - who was formerly
a Green Lantern had defected to the dark
stars and then taken over the leadership
of the team now the reason why this
matters is because when he takes out
gold face who was basically a background
guy he's like a see less level villain
but he had killed tomar ray during
Infinite Crisis I think it was and so
tomar ray of course was the father of
tomar - and that's why - amar - kills
gold face because he basically says you
are going to die for the crime that you
committed and that's the nature of the
dark stars that is extreme and it's
hardcore
and so when Hal Jordan arrives on the
scene and starts going through and
basically analyzing the bones of gold
face he essentially realizes look this
was done by a dark start and that's what
really turns his attention here because
what it means is the dark stars have
become active they've won return and to
begun initiating their campaigns and
much like the Green Lantern's which
we'll see here in a little bit the dark
stars can actually bring people to their
cause they can make they can turn them
into dark stars and so we're very Alan
shows up initially you know is a cool
conversation between the two because one
of the things that Hal Jordan has been
suffering from and this is something
that I think that Venditti and them are
really kind of moving cool I'm moving
backwards is it how Jordan might become
parallax again and the reason why is
because he's had a lot of negative
thoughts when it's come to his role as a
superhero when it's come to the various
super villains that are out there and
one of the big things he's talked about
is is it really a bad thing if we kill
people who commit crimes a dead man
can't be a repeat offender it's an
extreme perception but there is some
some legitimacy and merit to it and so
in response to this you know be really
kind of talks him down a little bit but
this has been an ongoing theme with Hal
Jordan since the events of dark nights
metal and even before that Hal Jordan
has routinely seen death and destruction
over and over and over again and the
question he has to ask is what's the
point of being a cop if we're always
late would it really be a bad thing to
stop the crimes before they happen and
it's one of the things that he says to
how I get where you're coming from but
these thoughts can't lead anywhere but
bad it could lead you back to that dark
place that you were before and how
Jordans response is yeah but that might
not be the worst thing and so it's it's
it's interesting here it's a great
exchange between the two it's one of
reasons why the flash and Hal Jordan
have always bounced off each other so
well in terms of how they were written
because they're the the character
interactions between the two not really
the battles they fight alongside in or
anything like that but the conversations
between the two or what makes them so
interesting and so picking up with Guy
Gardner we end up having guys show up to
a bar only to be met by arkillo now
again for those of you guys who were
playing a little bit of catch-up here if
you saw my previous videos arkillo was a
long-standing member of the Sinestro
Corps for a very very long time one of
his very first members and so where he
had gone through and routinely been a
bad guy as geoff johns run you know
basically reached its conclusion or at
least when he was writing it and then
robert Venditti took over and then DC
rebirth happened we started to see this
kind of shift between the two most
notably we saw where the Sinestro Corps
and the Green Lantern Corps teamed up
and where there was a lot of bitterness
and anger between the two groups for
arkillo and Guy Gardner they actually
became close friends to this whole thing
between the two this is really what kind
of boils down to like a back-alley deal
they're really not supposed to be
meeting with each other for the Green
Lantern's they don't really mind but for
the Sinestro Corps it's you do not mean
with Green Lantern's you do not
associate with them talk to them if you
see one you kill them but with Guy
Gardner and arkillo talking to each
other Guy Gardner basically says look
man there's a much bigger threat out
there the dark stars are rising and the
dark stars do not have a moral compass
they don't believe in truth and justice
or any of that stuff they believe that
if you commit a crime you're guilty and
you're done and that's it and so it's
it's it's extreme it's it's really
heavy-handed and that's kind of what guy
Gardner says because of what's going on
with the dark stars rising there's
essentially this point now where the
Green Lantern's are sending out what
amounts to an SOS every single Ally
that's out there they are running and
they are grabbing except for the ones
based on earth for the most part
you have kyle rayner transition to him
where he meets up with caddy now again
cabbie is basically the Han Solo of the
DC Universe it's really what he is and
it's cool but one of the things that's
happened here is that he's basically
modified his ship because he would
travel throughout the known universe and
he was basically a guy that would get
people to places where they weren't
supposed to be or get them through like
that channels and so on and so forth but
for what Guy Gardner needs they have to
leave the current universe and so what's
happened here is cabbie has basically
bought a mother box essentially on the
black market which would allow him to
leave the universe and travel to the
realm of the new gods and that's exactly
what happens what they end up doing is
travelling directly to where the new
gods are located on now of course again
kind of transitioning from there we pick
up with Jon Stewart in what's probably
one of the greatest moments ever when he
shows up here he shows up to basically
gain the aid of General Zod which is a
difficult thing to do but the funny
thing about this is that where Zod
immediately goes to attack Jon Stewart
cracks him in the hand with brass
knuckles and initially it seems like the
brass knuckles are made out of a hard
like construct but they're not they're
actually brass knuckles made of
Kryptonite now that's just the most boss
ass thing I've ever heard of it's beast
like using brass knuckles made of
kryptonite it's like one of the coolest
things ever it's like this genius idea
and so it's basically Jon Stewart saying
hey look man do I have your attention
now because we need to have a
conversation you know I've got
kryptonite here so if I bring a close
enough it's only a matter of time before
you die so either we can talk or you can
die from here or we transition over to
basically striker Island penitentiary
and we end up picking up with Hector
Hammond now Hector Hammond has been a
background character in the Green
Lantern stories for quite some time and
the reason why was because he played a
very significant role when it came to
like the war of the green lantern stem
and things like that
brightest day so on and so forth and so
because of that it was really imagine a
desire of entity to break away from the
quote unquote traditional villains of
the Green Lantern mythos and start
focusing on other things and so for the
most part Hector Hammond is just kind of
been in the background the whole time
just sort of sitting in strikers Island
but with Hal Jordan showing up here what
it means is that times are dire because
Hector Hammonds not a guy that you just
trifle with he's not a guy you just wake
up and we'll find out why here a little
bit because what ends up happening is
basically how Jordan is met by the
arrival of atomic skull now atomic skull
has been the name of a couple different
people but the most notable one and the
one that's this here is Joseph Morgan
the reason why I say the most notable is
because that's essentially the most
popular one post-crisis
when it comes to Joseph Martin he is a
guy really whose whose strength
durability is really on far with like
Superman like he's really really capable
but the way he grew he gained his powers
was from the dominators storyline back
in the post-crisis landscape which was
then activating the gene bomb it was
DC's attempt to sort of quote-unquote
create a mutant concept the gene bomb
was a way for DC to basically kind of
Usher in this huge explosion of powers
into the DC Universe landscape and then
just kind of pick and choose who got to
have what and and try to build up heroes
and villains from there that's really
where atomic school comes from but again
transitioning back over we end up having
this Green Lantern who's basically
travelling to their destination and this
is really just Venditti showing us how
extreme the dark stars are because when
this Green Lantern is transporting a guy
who's guilty of murder the Green Lantern
basically tells the dark stars look you
guys got to get out of here you're
pretenders you guys have no idea what
you're doing
at which point this guy's basically
blown to pieces the prisoner himself is
completely destroyed and that's the end
of this guy so it's really designed to
say like the dark stars are pretty
lethal now of course with atomic skull
facing off against Hal Jordan not a
whole lot doing here it's just kind of
atomic school doing what atomic school
does he's essentially a good guy now
he's basically a warden for the prison
and you know keeping control of the
inmates but of course were it looks like
he's gonna get the better half of our
agency get the upper hand on on how
Jordan Hector Hammond wakes up and
essentially like shuts down the mind of
atomic skull and that's really the end
of him and so again it's kind of a cool
thing but it's basically this idea that
like Jon Stewart old some pretty
underhanded things because switching
switching back to him this is one of the
important things about Jon Stewart for
the most part before he became leader of
the Green Lantern Corps Jon Stewart was
in a lot of ways by the book now it
didn't mean he never broke the rules but
it does mean that for the most part he
followed the rules but becoming leader
of the Green Lantern Corps means that
sometimes you have to come to the
realization that some rules are meant to
be bent and others can be broken to
quote the matrix and so with this whole
thing he basically approaches Zod and
says look we know you hate Green
Lantern's you blame Green Lantern's for
the destruction of Krypton you asked the
question where was it where was Krypton
Green Lantern when the planet was
destroyed and that's a valid question
tomar Rey was nowhere to be found
you can't take your vengeance on tomar
ray because he's dead so you take your
vengeance on the entire Green Lantern
Corps but what if I told you you could
have your vengeance on tomar tube now on
the surface it seems kind of like well I
mean it's par for the course but when
you're someone like Jon Stewart who is
for the most part honor duty and loyalty
first it's one of these things where
he's sort of [ __ ]
praise a bit of Honor he just kind of
cast that aside for a second but it's a
small sacrifice for a much bigger win
and it was really necessary here I mean
things are just that drastic and that's
what this is designed to show it's
designed to show how drastic things are
that Jon Stewart would take this step
and so ultimately he gains the attention
of General Zod who says okay let's let's
have this conversation let's let's sit
down and let's talk and let's see what's
going on and so at this one when we
switch back over to our kilo and anguy
gardener and they're basically met with
the arrival of the dark stars basically
tomar tomar - and the dark stars no it's
kind of cool because this is how the
dark stars swindle people - their path
the dark stars base desire is it's
almost primal imagine a modified Red
Lantern ring it's kind of how this
scenes with a Red Lantern ring when
you're when you're chosen when this is
like you know you have great rage in
your heart you belong to the Red
Lanterns and the ring bonds itself to
you all this really means is that you
just kind of revert to a very primal
state and all you do is just take orders
with the dark stars you're still capable
in Retton and you're so capable of
rational thought but you've been to your
own extreme desires and that really kind
of complements the purpose of the dark
stars which is to eliminate everybody
who commits murder to have no real
inhibitions about taking life of those
you deemed to be guilty and so with Guy
Gardner himself he's approached by tomar
- who says look we both came from bad
situations and we've we've both dealt
with this shame of our fathers in a lot
of different ways so I give you the
opportunity would you like to take
revenge on your father for what he's
done and guard Garner's response is yes
and so this is when he's immediately
bonded with the Dark Star EXO mantle
basically and is made into one of their
group so again guy Gardner is the first
Green Lantern to fall prey to the dark
stars and of course with Hector Hammond
and and and Hal Jordan they essentially
just kind of like race off you know it's
and it's kind of cool because when it
comes to Hector Hammond he'd always
idolized Hal Jordan right I mean that
was one that was one of the funny things
about his character is that when Hector
Hammond first met Hal Jordan he
considered him to be just somewhat of a
goof really once had to realize he was
the Green Lantern
it was always Hector sort of chasing
after him trying to be the hero that Hal
Jordan was because in the mind of Hector
it was the heroes get the girls the
heroes are the brave guys they get the
adoration they get the fame they get all
that kind of stuff I want that so I
should be a hero but it was particular
attention to Hal Jordan himself and so
that's why you know Hector Hammond has
always kind of been like the ultimate
fan even if a little bit extreme and a
little bit you know we're
in terms of how he doesn't he's always
kind of been the ultimate fan and so
that's why you see he's along for the
ride but he kind of celebrates the
chance to face off alongside Hal Jordan
now house warren is not too happy about
it you know it's just something that he
needs to do because of the power Hector
Hammond has with his telepathic
abilities having been enhanced recently
and so again picking up with a father of
Guy Gardner with Roland Gardner this is
actually interesting because Guy Gardner
shows up and says rolling Gardner you
know used to be the crap out of me your
penalty is death and this is intense
because Guy Gardner has just kind of
fallen down to his darker side so again
switching back to Hector and and Hal
Jordan this is this is a really really
awesome exchange here because what
happens is Hector basically starts
talking to howl and says look I can do
anything with my powers like like
anything that you want me to do I can
basically create all manner of illusions
and this instance he shows how Jordan
all of the villains in the DC Universe
who have all been killed by Hector
Hammond and Hal Jordan kind of freaks
out about that and says this is
ridiculous I don't want to do anything
like that and Hector's response is yes
you do I've read your mind this is what
you truly want no no this is not Hector
Hammond being manipulative at the moment
this is the most visceral and real thing
that Hal Jordan feels Hal Jordan wants
to see the death of all the villains on
a base level Hal Jordan becoming
parallax is only a matter of time
because he's falling back down to this
path of just darkness and doing whatever
it takes to win and so when House says
look you don't know what you're talking
about none of this is true Hector says I
always listen I hear everything just
because I'm unconscious doesn't mean my
brain is unconscious I hear everything
that goes on and it kind of flashes back
to the conversation that that Hal Jordan
had with Superman at the end of Dark
Knight's Medal when he when he when he
talks to him and says maybe it wouldn't
be the worst thing to destroy all the
villains like I could kill Hector
Hammond right now and what anybody
really care again
that darkness is showing itself that
darker side of Hal Jordan is kind of
coming back and so Hector's response is
don't worry how I will fix everything I
will make everything okay I will take
care of all the villains for you and you
won't have any blood on your hands all I
need for you to do is to stay out of the
way and he does this by wiping the mind
of Hal Jordan to where Hal Jordan
doesn't remember anything about himself
doesn't know his name doesn't know his
power or anything his mind is completely
and totally white and it's just like wow
I mean it's it's crazy to see that
happen now the other half of this is
that with the dark stars themselves one
of the things that they do is they
basically teleport in and teleport out
and so this makes them exceedingly
difficult to catch no one really knows
exactly where they're going to what
to say they don't know if they're
teleporting to a location to one planet
to take care of somebody and then
teleporting to another planet and
there's a lot of space out there the
only way to really be able to know where
they're going is to have a green lantern
set at every single planet in every
single star system across the entire
universe in every single galaxy which is
impossible it's absolutely unreasonable
to try to do that it would require
massive like it's just an astronomical
number of beings in order to make that
happen and so in response to this what
ends up happening is Jon Stewart hits up
do you know how General Zod it says look
what do you know about teleportation
disrupting technology and when it comes
to Zod he says well like most other
things in Krypton they were lost a time
but it would take weeks I mean we can
recreate one but it would take a long
time and Jon Stewart's response is I was
an architect Homeslice just wait and
watch what I do and it's the coolest
thing he did he basically recreates the
whole thing using using Green Lantern
tech and it's cool like it's it's pretty
badass to see but Joey back to Guy
Gardner here one of the cool things is
that where he I mean not really cool
that he's get ready to you know kill his
dad or kill Oh flies in and basically
stops him now this is not arkillo
looking for a tried and true [ __ ] he's
doing this as a friend you know he's
he's stepping in it's like it's like
punching a drunk friend in the face and
order to get them to calm down and keep
them from doing something stupid that's
what it's full stances here you do not
want to kill your pops you think you do
and this dark star energy is telling you
to but you don't really want to because
if you do this the instant it happens
you're gonna regret it you're going to
have crossed a line that you can't come
back from and it is my duty as your
friend to keep you from crossing that
line now the fight between the two is
pretty knocked down and dragged out
because it's our killer really fighting
more on a defensive side and Guy Gardner
fighting more on the offense of course
the reason why with our killer fighting
defenses because he's not looking to
kill Guy Gardner he's looking to
incapacitate him to defeat him but
because of the fact that it's really our
killer fighting fighting in a defensive
way it's him trying to reason with God
one of the things he says here is look
there was a time when I was beyond
redemption
I murdered I I did all manner of things
that simply did nothing more than make
me happy and the Sinestro Corps you know
basically fed into that it gave me the
ability did to instill fear across the
universe which made me one of the most
feared beings in the entirety of the
universe and I kept doing what I do only
doing it with more power but you guy
Gardner showed me a better way he showed
me a better path and your father
deserved that same Redemption your
father deserves a chance to be seen
to be shown a better path if he hasn't
found it already but if you really
believe that that all this was a waste
if you really believe that I is arkillo
in the EM incapable of being redeemed if
you really believe that I'm putting on
an act
but I'm faking it that none of this is
true then kill your father but if you
truly believe that I am a good guy if
you truly believe that I have redeemed
myself then you have to believe your
father can too and Dad that that right
there hits right in the field gets Guy
Gardner right in the fields and what he
does is it amps up his uh his willpower
and overpowers the Darkstar excellent
mantle so this is one of the cool caveat
said then dead he puts in here if a
green lantern has enough willpower they
can override the dark star X no mantle
it's so basically a way of saying it's
there it's there escape now what it also
means is it takes a lot of willpower
it's awesome to see this unfold now of
course this leads to kind of a quick
goodbye hey pop sorry for killing you
we'll grab a cup of a cup of coffee when
I get back push like it's basically him
bailing out this essentially him that's
kind of taken off and so jumping over it
you know to me back to Hal Jordon again
this is why things are so cool because
Hal Jordan as he's trying to figure out
who he is
as he feels confused he's met by this
sort of disembodied voice that says do
not listen to Hector Hammond ignore
Hector Hammond he's duping you he's
lying to you this is what he does and as
is Hector Hammond tries to combat this
voice this voice keeps getting stronger
and stronger and stronger and this is
when we end up finding out this planet
they've been on is a planet where Hal
Jordan forged his own ring now this is
important because this happened at the
very beginning of green lantern rebirth
Kyle Jordan was basically a renegade he
was an outcast he had taken the fall for
the Green Lantern Corps and essentially
said like I'm the reason they did all
these these things and so on and so
forth but the fact remains what ended up
happening is like no other Green Lantern
ever done before him what he managed to
do who was forge a ring out of his own
willpower his willpower was so strong he
forged a ring out of it I mean it would
be like you really needing a pencil and
just fabricating one out of thin air out
of your need to have one like it's it's
that's exactly what he did and so
because of this his willpower in this
planet is inherently strong this planet
is part and parcel to him and so his
willpower is dormant here it lays here
and that's what this willpower says the
reason why we've brought Hector ham into
this world is because we knew he would
try to mess with our mind and we needed
to be in a place where our willpower was
so extreme that we could overcome
insurmountable odds and so how's Jordan
basically REME urges with his own
willpower regains every ounce of himself
and then of course Hector Hammond
feels what's truly going on with Hector
being here what he says is these beans
that you're facing off against these
dark stars do not care about right and
wrong they don't care about moral
compasses they don't care about how you
define truth and justice all they care
about is that a person committed a crime
that person has to die and when you're
facing off against them you're gonna be
met with your own worst demons your own
worst fears you're gonna be met with all
these parts of yourself you're gonna
think have long since been lost and they
weren't they were there all the time
you just never dealt with him you had to
face your own fear this was Hector
Hammond helping out Hal Jordan in a very
very very big way a very important way
because what it means now is that Hal
Jordan is stronger with his willpower it
means that he knows what to expect in
this fight against the dark stars and he
won't really be taken by surprise and
what what the Hector kind of says here
is that it's not the things that you
that you believe it's not your moral
compass or anything like that that
define you as a hero it's what you do
just because you believe that people
should be saved doesn't mean you'll save
them it's the belief you'll save them
and then actually going out and saving
them that makes you a hero
that's what makes you who you are and
it's the only thing that matters you
cast aside these darker feelings you
cast aside this idea that people who all
committed crimes should basically be
eliminated and so he's kind of one step
away from parallax now notice this then
Danny doesn't say he'll never become
parallax he's just kind of a step away
from where he was before as it was kind
of a cool thing but in the middle of all
this we end up Tranio transitioning back
to Moga with Kilowog who basically
sounds the SOS because the dark stars
have vintage hacking the Green Lantern's
everywhere they find them and so in this
instance Kilowog kind of says okay weed
everybody to come back here and the
reason why is because the dark stars
have surrounded the entire planet of
Mogo and if given the ability to do so
they will destroy everyone here okay so
we are we're wrapping up Hal Jordan the
Green Lantern Corps here's a funny thing
this is it this is the end of Hal Jordan
the Green Lantern Corps in DC we birth
least I'm pretty sure it is it's the
final issue from what I understand what
they're doing is they're combining how
to run in the Green Lantern Corps with
Green Lantern's and so going forward
this is gonna be the new story which is
kind of interesting because as I
understand it Doomsday Clock was
supposed to have been done by now or
within the next month or two and it's
not they had they've kind of had to
extend it out in order to make make time
for the arc which I don't care Gary
Frank is amazing artist I'll wait until
the end of time to see the end of that
story so the day I died it's the end of
that story if it means Gary Frank will
keep drawing Gary Frank
as much time as you need man dude your
art is amazing but uh but nonetheless so
so basically this is the end of Hal
Jordan the Green Lantern Corps so
happily this is called the last charge
of the Green Lantern's which i think is
an amazing name but it's kind of cool
because what this does is it kind of
picks up with a little bit of a
narrative of sorts it really picks up
with the nature of the Green Lantern
Corps from the perspective of tomar -
and it's not the most significant thing
but it is kind of cool because what
tomar - basically says here is like when
he was younger he watched his father as
a Green Lantern and and it was it was
awe-inspiring and so with tomar - giving
us this bit of an explanation what we
know is that of course his father died
and tomar - took his place you know and
and with tomar - becoming a new Green
Lantern ultimately he was basically
dissuade by his father's death you know
for him it was crushing because it was
like okay where's the justice here like
where where's where's the response to my
father being killed you know and that's
one of the things that kind of drives
his carrot that's what he's been doing
so far is that in his mind the man who
killed his father still alive his father
is dead but this man still alive
apparently he was worthy of a second
chance well worthy according to who but
who decided with an absolute certainty
this guy deserves a second chance and
whoever whoever said that was wrong and
so in turn tomar - killed that guy of
course after having taken over the
mantle of the dark stars and and that's
what kind of leads us to the current
moment now the big thing about this is
that Jon Stewart's initial response is
we have to defeat the start the dark
stars without killing them we have to
show the world or show the universe that
justice can be served without murdering
people and you know whether it's
justified or unjustified
but here's the funny thing when it comes
to head-to-head confrontations like this
wars in this capacity are won by those
who are willing to do what the others
want - armies who were even in power
fighting against each other it'll come
down to which one's ever you know
whichever ones willing to do what the
other ones not you know whoever is
willing to push the limits go to the
ends of the earth and and basically do
what needs to be done and so in a lot of
ways Jon Stewart is handicapping his own
team he's handicapping the Green
Lantern's by him saying look you can't
kill the dark stars we have to change
their hearts and minds and while that's
admirable at the end of the day it
really seems kind of pointless because
how can he change the mind of a person
who's hell-bent on revenge the one thing
they want is the one thing you're
denying them and so as it's interesting
you know in this situation so while all
this conversations going on it's kind of
a funny little tidbit here while all
this conversations going on Hector
Hammond is trying to make everybody
happy
and he's doing it by like modifying how
they see everything and first through it
like a birthday party and then they're
like Edda at a game and like a baseball
game who the hell goes to baseball games
anymore and
then there are then they're all on the
beach which is kind of funny and it's
just like like he's just making him jump
through all these different things
finally they told me call it off but
it's kind of funny like I like done like
Hector him in now like I want to see
more of that kind of Hector Hammond for
those of you guys who are new to comics
this is a kind of thing that changes
people like like people will go through
and they'll read carries off I've seen
it for years and years and years years
people will go through and they'll read
characters and won't really care about
them and then like a thing will happen
and fans will be like you know what I
like that guy now and like oh don't like
that person you know they'll be I love
Carol Danvers now or I hate Carol
Danvers now or something like that
though they'll be on this position we're
like though they're like their view of
that character will change because of
like one thing because of one instance
of how it's written and so it's it's
kind of cool and it's kind of funny but
nonetheless with the Green Lantern's
facing off against the dark stars this
is really more of a repeat of the early
stages of the Sinestro Corps award for
those of you guys who remember that when
the Green Lantern's were not authorized
to kill they were basically running and
dodging all the time they were
constantly in a state of retreat because
the Sinestro Corps were not limited by
the bounds of killing they killed Green
Lantern's everywhere they found it and
so anytime a Green Lantern ran into a
member of the Sinestro Corps or multiple
members they would basically take
potshots and they would they would they
would date hightail it out of there and
if the Sinestro Corps was chasing after
then they would just play retreat or
they would play defense until they got
to a larger number of Green Lantern's
fend off as best they could and get out
of there it wasn't until the Green
Lantern's were allowed to kill till the
battle became more even as it was it's a
really interesting situation because
when you have these dark stars what
makes them so difficult what makes them
so deadly here is the fact that they can
teleport they teleport around also keep
in mind that while they all do have
their own individual perceptions that
their tactical capabilities are all
linked telepathically by the controllers
which in turn are used by by tomar too
and so what this means is that he's kind
of like a one-man army right like he's
kind of directing all these members who
are all basically otamatone and in turn
like they're launching all these
different strike attacks at the ethic
Green Lantern's they're all you know
using this this massive coordinated
attack and then teleporting in and out
and it makes them almost impossible to
catch and so this is a whole new kettle
of beans because for the most part it is
you know you got like Orion on this
little scooter thing
his little scooter thing even of course
you've got like General Zod here and
there's a lot of restraint that's being
orchestrated because it's basically a
battle on two fronts
you've got the Oh a massive number of
the dark stars who were facing off
against like Hal Jordan and Orion in
Colerain oh and Gardner and those guys
and then you've got the dark stars who
were back at Mogo attacking the
headquarters and so it's cool to see
this unfold because you're talking about
people coming together who would
normally never fight together and seeing
General Zod fight alongside the the land
to like fight alongside arkillo of the
Sinestro Corps and the other Green
Lantern's and then of course like like
Orion is actually pretty cool because
you would never really see anything like
this now of course with regards to to
General Zod himself and even with the
Guardians of the Universe stepping in by
and large their power is not really
enough to stop the dark stars because
the dark stars were able to overpower
the controllers who of course are
formidable in and of themselves but
again having a hive mind being able to
strategically plan out entire events and
knowing where every other member of the
dark stars are in striking in a
coordinated fashion makes things
incredibly difficult because you gotta
remember this is basically a battle on
the spot for for the Green Lantern's
it's just kind of the dark stars are
suddenly here and so it's not like they
had a huge amount of time to plan out
how they're going to Co to strategically
attack and even if they did there's no
guarantee it would have gone to form
because they're not all linked to the
same mind and so that's one of the
things that Orion points out here we're
way out of our league like we can't
fight an enemy like this head-on
because we're getting absolutely
decimated by these guys they're just too
tight too cold too strategic there's
nothing we can do here and so how drawer
Dhin is kind of like the Trojan horse
right like how Jordan grabs Hector
Hector Hammond and they take off to the
controller's where their minds are
linked and the idea of Hector Hammond is
to sever the telepathic link and it's
kind of funny because Venditti plays on
this idea that it's going to be like an
almost insurmountable task and it's
gonna be wildly difficult to achieve and
so when he tells Hector ham and here's
what I need you to do Hector ham is like
okay done and and then that's it so I
was like okay so we've achieved this
okay what's what's what's the next thing
that we do now and it kind of Kansa Hal
Jordan by surprise he's kind of like why
me I didn't really expect it to be that
easy but that's cool so so this
basically sends kind of a psychic shock
to the minds of all the dark stars and
even if it only grants a brief moment of
reprieve
that's all the Green Lantern's need to
swoop in and try to take out the entire
dark star group in one fell swoop now of
course it doesn't quite work as planned
because even when you're talking about
the dark stars losing their telepathic
power
they're still very very very dangerous
in their own right at this moment right
now they're more akin to the old you
know old dark stars from like the 1990s
the the original iteration of the group
but for this purpose they're still
pretty capable now the other half of
this is that they are still teleporting
around in rapid fashion and that's one
of the other things what Jon Stewart had
done and she kind of orchestrated this
two-pronged attack the first was to cut
off their telepathic connection using
Hal Jordan and the second one was to use
to tell a teleportation disrupter he
built to block off their ability to
teleport around and so that's what ends
up happening here tomar 2 connoisseurs
talking trash jumps in front of Hal
Jordan and he can't teleport away
h-how'd Rinna gets the better of him
gets the attack and that's when they
start to panic and that's what they have
to get out of there at the same time Jon
Stewart shows up with a full contingent
of the Green Lantern's and says okay now
it's time for us to start taking the
fight to the dark stars
this is classic Green Lantern's
storytelling it's one of the coolest
things that you know that you get to see
one of these are the Green Lantern's and
what makes them interesting in a lot of
ways at Marvel acts is there's no like
disheveled mess you go and look at the
cosmic landscape in Marvel Comics you
walk into a comic book stories you say
okay I want to read cosmic marvellous
like we'll take your pick you've got
guardians of the galaxy you've got Nova
you've got quasar you've got any number
of the other things who are out there
like you've got all these these huge
expanse of things you've got the Thanos
book you got Silver Surfer you got all
this stuff with DC it's not nearly that
complicated with DC you don't have to
worry about the Eternals you know neil
gaiman's Eternals or anything like that
it's just Green Lantern's done super
simple and doing that basically allows a
rider to consolidate into focus strictly
on the Green Lantern's with whatever it
is they happen to be fighting against
and whoever it is they want to invoke
keep things simple and action-packed at
the same time and it works incredibly
well and so having these guys face off
against each other like this ultimately
what it ends up doing is it comes down
to how to earn himself because in
reality again the plan of Jon Stewart's
kind of failed and that's one of the
failings of Jon Stewart is is this
belief that well we have to make sure
that we stay the course we have to make
sure we do the right thing and while
that's admirable admiration does not win
wars what wins Wars is doing what needs
to be done and Jon Stewart at the end of
the day is not doing what needs to be
done if they truly want to win they have
to kill all the dark stars to cut them
off entirely in response to this how
Jordan kind of picks up the slack and
says well then fine because I'm
basically walking talking willpower I'll
channel that directly into the dark
stars themselves and so where he faces
off directly against home r2 he's able
to hold his own I meet Omar to is by no
means a slouch but the funny thing about
this is
in this fight between the two tomar -
really keeps asking the question how can
you be okay with the fact that your dad
died like that you know because it was
essentially negligence it was a it was
an aircraft that wasn't ready to fly it
took off it blew up the most predictable
scenario happened and your pop sign in
the process how can you be okay with
this and how Jordans response was well
because it's made me who I am if
everything that's ever happened to me in
my life and everything I've ever said
and ever done and has ever been done to
me and has ever been said to me has led
me to this place right now it couldn't
have been that bad because this made me
the hero that I am but for Tomar - he's
driven by guru and he's driven by grief
and driven by rage and revenge and all
these different things has sort of come
together to coalesce and turn him into a
Dark Star and so in response to this you
know Hal Jordan is for the most part
able to defeat him he's able to take him
out because again at the end of the day
tomar - is no he's no Hal Jordan and so
is when this is going on suddenly you
have General Zod who steps up and this
is why I like Zod so much because odds
like okay so there's basically those who
seek victory and those who are too weak
to find it and so in this instance he
says like I'm just gonna I'm gonna start
killing people but yeah that's what this
is now these guys are gonna keep on
fighting and fighting and fighting until
they win they'll fight to the last man
and so if that if what they want to do
is fight to the last man then I'll just
help them along the way
and so in the process you goes to kill
one of the dark stars Jon Stewart Guy
Gardner Kyle Rayner step in and say do
not kill him we have to find a better
way but house worden again steps in
saves the day
how Jordan basically ends up taking like
all the willpower that makes him who he
is and handling it directly into the
dark stars energy source and then by
doing that basically imbues like like in
views all of them with willpower now the
reason why he does this is because
previously Guy Gardner had told him look
I used willpower in order to overcome my
Dark Star suit and how Jordan is nothing
if not strategically intelligent he's
not the sharpest tool in the shed
you're never gonna see how Jordan go to
MIT he's just too dumb but with regards
to like military combat training and
with regards to like experience and
being out there the guys got it were
accounts and so putting two and two
together he literally channels willpower
through their energy source and men
basically overrides the darkstar
technology and so with the Dark Star
technology being overridden it's like
removing a Red Lantern ring the person
returns to their normal self and Tomar -
is literally just driven by like grief
at this point he's just kinda like I
can't believe I did all this today that
I went on a rampage like this and did
all these different things and in a
moment when General Zod goes to try to
kill him what to him are two ends up
doing is actually killing himself he
ends his own life and so he's just kind
of like I'm beyond redemption there's
nothing I
can do to make up for this and so he
took the only step he felt he could buy
basically ending his own life and so in
this moment what is up happening is of
course his ring races off to go find a
replacement the war is basically done
the dark stars are gone the sources
ended the other there really doesn't
seem to be any indication they'll make
their return and of course this leads
basically into the epilogue and it's a
cool thing because remember ever since
edge of oblivion
the Green Lantern number has been
reduced to almost zero when you had this
massive Green Lantern Corps there was
basically thrust all the way to the very
beginnings of the universe and had to
work their way back to the modern day a
so many of them were lost in the process
now in reality it was a way for DC to
thin the herd it was a way for D it was
it was like DC's version of decimation
for the x-men get rid of the lanterns
that just didn't really have a plot
point er they really couldn't do
anything with and then keep the ones
that everybody loved along with a few
others just to bolster the ranks and
then send the group back out into the
main DC universe at the beginning of
rebirth and so with this whole thing
happening what they need are more Green
Lantern's and so that's why John Stewart
basically ends up you know kind of
beginning the ceremony which basically
sees the creation of a whole new host of
rings being sent out directly into the
universe itself and seeking out a whole
new host of Green Lantern's and so it's
basically everything returning back to
the status quo it's almost like Robert
Van Diddy's way of saying ok let's
transition everything back to right
before Jeff John started Green Lantern
where we have this vast number of
lanterns and we can basically kind of go
through and start crafting whole new
stories and so at the tail end of this
we get to see the return of a familiar
character we get to see how Jordan
returning to earth traveling to KO city
and meeting Carroll fares and this is
actually pretty exciting this is a big
deal we haven't seen her for a very long
time and so it's cool because there's a
lot of questions that come out of this
will she return to being a star sapphire
is she just going to be the love
interest of Hal Jordan are they gonna
have a life together pop out a couple
kids but we really don't know what
direction things are gonna go in with
regards to the two of them in this comic
book line but I'm very very excited to
find out but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]